thank you Mr chairman and members of the
subcommittee uh good morning for the
record my name is Mike winsat I Serv as
director of the waste management
division for the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services I'm
joined this morning by Leah McKenna who
is the administrator of our Solid Waste
Management Bureau and we're pleased to
uh be before you this morning to give
you a brief update of uh where we're at
in our Solid Waste rulemaking process
particularly with respect to chapter 800
uh regarding landfill
requirements um so at as you indicated
Mr chair um you know as we discussed uh
at our last meeting on December 5th uh
Dees sent out a draft of of chapter 800
for informal comment on October 18th of
last year um and then we took comment
into November and we received a lot of
feedback during that that 3-we comment
period and we made adjustments to the
draft based on comments that we received
um a few of those there's a number of
those but a few of those just to to
highlight there was some language
regarding um citing and monitoring Wells
and we received some input from the
public on that and we made some
adjustments with respect to that to make
it explicitly clear that they were based
on the needs uh to adequately monitor
the landfill and and the associated
infrastructure around the landfill um we
uh also U made an adjustment that made
it clear that no
online that landfills could not unline
landfills could not be used um even for
construction and demolition debris that
if a CN landfill specific landfill were
cited it would need to have a liner and
then uh we also added some quality
assurance and quality control
requirements with regard to
geosynthetics because the previous rule
made reference to geomembranes which is
only one class of geosynthetics so we
made it clear that there needed to be
specific QA and QC um monitoring
requirements with respect to uh all
geosynthetics that are used in in
landfill
construction uh so uh with that we we
did meet with the waste management
council at their monthly meeting on
January 18th and we presented this set
of rules to them uh we had a very robust
session where we we we filled it a
number of questions um from counselors
and uh we uh we did did our best to
answer their questions um I I will note
too that in this interim period we've
also been approached once that draft was
released to the public we've been
approached by um a number of members of
the regulated community and have met
with them at their request to address
their concerns and comments and some of
those concerns and comments that we
heard surprised us a little um they were
relative to sighting requirements and
the impact of those um on facility
expansion and facility sighting um and
about the the practicability of those
and and what that might do to the
universe of sites that maybe could be
used to to site a landfill or or to or
to expand an existing landfill um there
were concerns expressed significant
concerns expressed about the
constructibility of some of the uh
design and construction changes that we
were proposing and and whether they were
even just feasible to construct or or
even advisable and whether they provided
a measure of uh of a
um added protection that was worth the
risk of of actually having difficulty
constructing them in the field um there
were also some concerns expressed um
about both short and long-term Financial
impact of some of the provisions some of
which which were were U proposed were
suggested to be very significant on a
level that would um threaten uh the
operation or or at least at the very
least the the affordability of tipping
fees that might be associated with
landfilling and so we've been listening
to those um and we continue to review
that we um there some of those are
aligned with what we heard at the
council at the waste management Council
a number of them are and so we uh
anticipate that we're going to be
modifying the draft um to try to address
some of those concerns and what we've
suggested is that the waste Council
which is scheduled to have its next
monthly meeting on February 15th that we
would come before the council at that
meeting to um not do a full sort of
proposal or presentation on the whole
rules but maybe to focus and talk about
changes that we made since the 18th of
January so we expect that'll be an
important um uh you know time with the
council and then following that in order
to stay on schedule we anticipate that
we would uh then be filing the initial
proposal for the rules which of course
kicks off the formal rulemaking process
um by the end of February to keep us on
schedule for um going through that
process to get to a final proposal
before July 1 um and I I would remind
everyone that again all of this is sort
of extracurricular if you will it's no
less important because the result of
that but none of this process other than
us going before the council is
necessarily required but I think it's
been a very important process we're
really glad that we have engaged the
public um on this as we as we worked on
these very important rules and um once
we file our initial proposal then of
course uh the the formal process which
is set out in the law uh will be that we
will um schedule a public hearing for
those rules and then typically that
would be followed by uh three or four
week public comment period so so folks
will have an opportunity to provide oral
comments or submit and written testimony
at the public hearing and then there'll
be an opportunity for further written
comments to be submitted during that
comment period and then once that is all
received we would review all that um
make any changes that we thought were
appropriate based on the comments
received and then proceed to a final
proposal probably around May or early
June so that's a nutshell of where we're
at um with respect to this Ru making and
we're happy to entertain questions that
just the what what's been the flavor of
the comments you've gotten back in terms
of
uh who is who is responding is it mostly
corporate is it private citizens is it
noos nonprofits um well who's who's been
engaged sure in in the early going you
know during these you know going all the
way back to March we you know we've had
a listening session in March and then
another one in August with a follow by a
common period and then this one in
October into November that's been a
broad mix of both um the regulated
Community the and the public at large
and and legislators um but since we
propos since we file U presented our our
draft proposal to the Council on January
18th most of the feedback we've been
hearing has come from the regulated
Community which you know obviously is in
a position to look at these and really
understand specifically with with those
in hand understand how they might impact
their facility or their plans to expand
their facility and um and and put that
in the context of the existing facility
to see how it might change their
operations their plans for the future or
their costs for operating so we've been
hearing from those folks primarily since
January 18th okay representative Murray
uh thank you Mr chair um thanks for
taking my question when you say
regulatory committee are you talking
state federal are you talking a mixture
of both oh no I'm sorry when i' say the
regulatory the regulated Community I not
regulatory but regulated Community those
that's the industry that's the the
landfill operators the the waste
management companies
sure representative
Jana thank you Mr chairman thank you
both for being here and thank you for
taking my question and and it's related
to this kind of you know thinking about
how the draft changes and the different
iterations and trying to understand why
uh changes are are made and and i' admit
I get a little nervous when I get this
sense that the regulated Community is
has what seems to be kind of privileged
access to shaping that process or at
least has more weight in the development
of those policies than uh people who are
affected in the community who aren't reg
you know part of these regulated
entities but so one of the things I'm
hoping is eventually when the next draft
kind of comes through if there's a way
ultimately we could have some type of
tracked changes or if we could have some
type of detailed discussion about what
has changed and why and and one example
I'll give which I wanted to ask about
this morning has to do with changes
between the October draft and the the
January draft regarding the hydraulic
conductivity um so that I see that there
has been a new
uh the H insertion of a reference to
hydraulic conductivity in
804 believe it's
80402 if I have that correct uh yeah
80402 C I think um and that's new right
and that that refers specifically to
undisturbed in sit2 sites right so
you're talking about what the conditions
have to be um of the site before any
preparation work is done so I appreciate
that something has been inserted there
even though though I have a question
about that I see between the October
draft and the January draft in section
80503 the the existing rules right now
have a hydraulic conductivity rate of
one time 10
the4th the October draft enhanced that
protection to 1 time 10
theg5 the most recent draft changed that
back to 1 time 10 fourth and this is
where my concern about the regulated
community and their ability to shape the
process comes in so we had a
strengthening of 10
times of that hydraulic conductivity
rate in
805 right after the the site has been
prepared and then it was taken back to
to 1 time 10 the4 so could you share
with us kind of how that process
happened because it seemed to me that we
were moving in a more protective
Direction 1 time 10 the 5th is main
standard as I understand it and then
between October and January where there
has been discussions as you said with
kind of regulated groups it has now been
taken back to 1 time 10 to the4 it's a
weakening by 10 times so could you kind
of talk us through um you know what kind
of input that you got that led you to
decide that it wasn't worth
strengthening the
standard sure so I I think this is a
complex area that still we're still
hearing a lot about this and um I think
a lot of it goes to the issue of the
heterogeneity of the geology in New
Hampshire there's a concern you know the
regulated Community is um they're
regulated so they read rules very
carefully and they they understand that
they're going to be held to those rules
so they they they tend to kind of look
at it and say okay in the worst case
scenario how could this upset my my
situation my facility and they've looked
at their existing facilities and express
concerns that you know maybe the the
overarching soil quality if you look at
it on a macro scale would meet that
standard but they know that there may be
places within the formation where if
they drill a well in one location and do
a hydraulic conductivity test it's not
going to meet that standard and so
they've expressed concerns about that
and we're we're struggling with that
right now we're trying to look at that
um and figure out how to write the rule
and how to essentially what I would say
is what we're trying to do our goal all
along here has been to develop rules
that are protective of human health in
the environment
um while ensuring that facilities you
know can that that can provide adequate
needed and affordable Waste Management
Services and capacity for the state's
waste can actually be cited constructed
and operated right and that's a delicate
balance right because if we you know it
would be easy to say well the soils have
to all be
clay but then the reality is we don't
have places like that and if we did they
might not be geotechnically suitable to
site and and construct a landfill or we
could say we're not going to worry about
it and then you'd have something
something that's maybe cited on you know
a very permeable material with a lot of
cobbles and void spaces that would move
contaminants very quickly so we have to
figure out where in the middle of that
um gives us the level of protection that
we really want and desire while also not
eliminating all the sites or creating a
situation where the way we write the
rule makes it really uncertain about
whether a facility can demonstrate that
compliance with the rule so this is an
area that still is in in play here I
think um and and we're working on um I I
will tell you the industry read these
rules and felt like we were trying to
put them out of business and then the
public or or other members who are
concerned more about the protective side
look at it and say well the agency's
just meeting with the a with the
regulated community and going to give
them whatever they want so we're in the
middle of that and what we're trying to
do is make sure what I just said to you
is really what we're trying to do I've
told that to the industry because they
looked at these rules and said well
you're just trying to eliminate all of
our facilities because what they said is
that none of the facilities we're
operating right now would ever be cited
if these rules were in place and if
these rules were in place um none of our
facilities would be able to be expanded
so we took that seriously because we
have an overarching role here to make
sure we you know the statute tells us
we're to implement a solid waste
management program that provides for um
safe and adequate capacity to manage
waste in the state so we're just trying
to balance all that and candidly that's
a really difficult thing right now in
these areas about the subgrade and and
the Institue soils conductivity we're
really still those that's very much
something we're still working on but
that's what has brought us to that right
that to be honest with you that was a
surprise we did not think we were going
to hear that um and so we're evaluating
that information and and trying to
figure out what is a way to craft this
rule so that it we really do provide
that level of protection that we that we
don't have facilities cited on really
inappropriate sites that are too
conductive but also leave enough
availability of sites in the state to
future uh so at some point could we get
uh some information regarding I mean is
it true that none of our
landfills would be able to meet that
requirement of 10 to the neg5 and you
know what evidence has there been
presented that's what I'm wondering is
is like how do we know that that's true
I understand that they told you that but
how do we and I understand that you were
doing your due diligence I'm not
questioning that but I'm wondering kind
of how we know that is our hydrogeology
so vastly different for example from
Maine that they can site at 10 to the
neg5 and we can't and also do all of our
landfills currently would they all fail
10 to the negative fth yeah I I mean
we're we have a lot of information about
these facilities and as we learn these
concerns we we're looking back through
our records to understand that um I I
will say I don't really want to debate
Maine because I I I don't know enough
about their rules necessarily to do that
effectively and there they're a sister
State and I don't want to speak but I
would seriously doubt that the landfill
SED and operate in Maine right now meet
at 10 the minus standard I think that's
very unlikely all right thank you thank
chair so I just wanted to go back to um
what you were saying about meeting with
um I don't know stakeholders or whatever
during this time the public comment is
not open
correct right we um we we have not
sought out any of these meetings members
of the regulated Community have
requested to meet with us to express
their concerns and as we do with any
member who does any member of the public
that does that we've we've we've granted
them a meeting and we've talked to them
okay so
um but these are like xparte meetings
where in a sense an industry while
you're working on rules could I mean I'd
like to know exactly who you've had
these meetings
with like a list of everybody that's
come and had meetings with you when
we're underneath writing rules and these
rules can affect these industries so to
me just to go back piggyback on our
representative gerana I don't understand
how we have something that's protective
and then we dial it back this is not the
only section in here from October um to
January where you've weakened things so
the October 23 draft for example um it
had in here a 24 year old federal law
that was that you guys were lered to um
it was line F on page six at the bottom
now it's completely removed you
completely remove new Ms wlfs subject to
the requirements of section 503 of the
wendle 8 H Ford Aviation investment D
reform it's completely gone and it says
here shall not be cited within six miles
of certain smaller public airports da d
d so that's federal law that's now been
taken out like I don't understand why
would why we're we're dialing things
back and then you tell us that you're
having expart meetings when there's no
public comment okay yeah so there's a
lot to unpack there so the first issue
about the aviation and I don't remember
exactly how it worked but that is still
in place there's when we write rules
there are ways that certain provisions
of existing state law or state rules or
federal law or rules are invoked and I
can assure you that still applies um
it's just what the fact that it may have
been taken out of a section or
referenced in a different way doesn't
mean that we're not observing that so
and if you want details on that I'm not
prepared to give them to you right now
but I can I can get those for you um
with respect to meetings that we've had
um that that is is any member of the
public who wishes to meet with us about
the rules can request a meeting and
these folks have done that uh to answer
your question uh The Operators owners
and operators of three landfill
facilities have requested to meet with
us the turnkey facility that's operated
by Waste Management the betham facility
that's operated by cassella and the
anders gagen Valley Regional Refuge
disposal District facility mon carbury
in Success New Hampshire all of those
members of reg Community um have
requested to meet with us and have
expressed concerns about a number of the
provisions of the rules and I will say
that um you know over the years as we we
we regulate a lot of different we have a
lot of different regulated communities
and when we do rules we do talk with
them and we need to because I can assure
you if we didn't talk with them um about
the rules we would make huge mistakes in
our Ru making and there are examples of
that and um when we don't speak with
them and we plow ahead with something we
think is absolutely fine and appropriate
we often learn it has unintended
consequences or impacts that we could
not foresee and um so it's both
appropriate and helpful for us to speak
with the regulated Community when we
were working on rules particularly rule
sets that are as complex as these rules
and have you know there's a lot of
moving parts to how these rules are
implemented and even with we have
excellent Engineers who were do such
great work and whove worked really hard
on these rules but they're not in a
position to anticipate every impact of
every rule that they propose and that's
why we need to hear from the regulated
Community about
that so to to be clear have you denied a
meeting with anyone else that has come
to of course no we would we would never
do that so you you
have met with everyone that asked for a
meeting anyone who's asked to meet with
us about the rules we've granted them a
representative H Haskins thank
you and thank you for taking my question
so your job is a difficult one as you
say you're kind of in the middle and our
job I think as I understand it is clear
that we have to represent the public we
recognize that we want industry in our
state um we want the needs of the public
to be met by the industry that provide
that but I'm not a scientist so I can't
um debate the conductivity of the soil
with you but I do recognize that we're
getting an application for a new
landfill that hasn't been done in I
don't know 30 years long
industry
has not Millions but a billion dollars
to put behind the advocacy that they're
making and so from my point of view I
want to be sure that as I represent the
citizens that we're giving the kind of
advocacy that they
expect and that the industry which has
those Hired Guns if you
will to come before you and make their
case don't outweigh the protection of
the public that I'm supposed to be
serving so so that's my dilemma and I
think what representative ger
highlighted is the kind of thing that
makes me nervous if we're going
backwards in protection then I don't
feel like we're doing our job or I'm
doing my job so you know we need
this independent entity this um person
who's not a consultant for the industry
to weigh in on these
hydrological numbers so that I can we
can have the confidence as we represent
the public that the other there
shouldn't be another side I mean we
should all be on the same side but that
again since protection I believe in
representing the public is my goal
that we have the kind of information
that we can then have that fair
conversation about the 10 times
backwards for protection um so that's
what concerns me and I don't have an
answer to it but I do think that I would
be more confident if we had that
independent entity that was not
Consulting for the
industry and maybe meet with that person
and have that conversation
although not a scientist I think I could
you know keep up fairly well because
they
represent the new information that we
have we know so much more now and I want
to make sure that that
knowledge is into the ru making by those
that don't have a vested
you
represent Jamal thank you Mr chairman uh
so I one of the questions I have as I
mentioned before I I appreciate I like
the fact that you've you've uh put in
specific hydraulic conductivity uh of
the undisturbed site so that seems to me
a really sensible and and I think good
protective measure in addition to then
uh a more a stricter conductivity
requirement when it comes to the site
once it's been developed so could you
talk talk a little bit about how you
determine what that uh what that
Criterion is for the
undisturbed site uh just because this is
a new part of the rules and you can
correct me if I'm wrong but it's not in
that that's that Criterion is not in
current rules so it is new if I'm not
mistaken but could you talk to me about
how it's determined what say the
undisturbed Criterion is um
yeah how that's arrived at sure I mean I
think it's a balancing act in the sense
that um you know ideally to be as
protective as possible we want the least
conductive soils um but then and so we
would go to presumably somewhere where
the soils were the least conductive but
still geotechnically capable of
supporting a landfill um that's probably
at a place where we wouldn't have sites
that would meet those criteria so we
arrived in our in our proposal
at um 10us 3 um that in in very broad
terms if you go to a hydrogeology
textbook that represents sort of the
average hydraulic cond conductivity of a
fine sand all right which clearly would
be geot technically stable but would
also you know not be as conductive as a
coarse sand or a sand with or a material
with much larger um Aggregates in it um
so what what we are hearing is that that
while that may be indeed the conditions
we have under portions of a lot of our
landfills it's by no means uniform it's
not there in that condition everywhere
you look under the landfill everywhere
in the formation and so the concerns
that had been expressed had been well
you know we're not sure we can meet that
and and what happens if we go in and we
do 10 borings and one of the borings all
nine of them meet the standard but one
of them doesn't meet the standard it's
more it's it's it's a it's more like a
coarse sand and and does that mean that
the whole s is off and that's what we're
hearing from folks who are concerned
about the proposed rule so we're as I
said that's something we're still
considering we're trying to sort out um
how we can craft that rule to ensure
that we still bias the system towards
very you know less less conductive soils
um while not eliminating so much uh of
Avail potential available land and one
of the candid problems here is that the
Practical aspects of citing a landfill
are that typically they tend to get
cited in um in in the past um in Old
played out Gravel Pit areas so you've
got areas and there are a lot of reasons
for that one is that um it takes a lot
of aggregate to build and operate a
landfill so every day that a landfill is
operating there's daily cover that's
needed there's construction that's going
on in the cell so having gra sand and
gravel deposits nearby are helpful for
you know operating a landfill making it
practicable otherwise you've got massive
amounts of truck traffic hauling in
aggregate from elsewhere whereas most
landfill operators you most landfills we
have that operation is happening on the
site so that's a practical consideration
um the other issue is that um in these
old played out pits typically maybe more
coar materials have been mined and there
are finer materials beneath them that
that were either not economically um uh
you know attractive to mine um and and
so the the pit stops operating
or you know obviously when you know in
the worst case scenario a pit gets mined
down to the groundwater table right and
then they stop then um so so there are a
lot of practical reasons why landfills
are cited um in those kinds of settings
um but those have you know uh
considerations too they may well be
located near surface waters they may be
located near more porest materials so
it's really a balancing act of trying to
figure out what are these appropriate
sites and also idea is if you're going
to site a landfill it can't be on a two
Acre Site right it's got to be a fairly
big site we're in a you know our state
has seen development over the years so
there are fewer and fewer large Parcels
of land that might be good candidates
for
landfill construction sighting or or
expansion so there's all that that gets
that gets factored in there so it's a
difficult dance to try to figure out how
do we make sure that any expansions or
new sightings of landfills are cited on
relatively low conductivity soils while
still making available some portfolio of
sites that could be used for that into
the future because we we look at that
and understand that landfilling although
we'd like to see it be a less prominent
role in our overall integrated system of
solid waste management for a number of
waste it's likely to still be the
technology that's used for decades ahead
and we need to make sure that we're not
creating a rule structure or a real
Paradigm that makes it impossible to
cite
those thank you thank you Mr chair um
thanks for taking my question so if I'm
hearing you correctly what you are
hearing from the regulated Community is
a concern potentially about a single
potential data point among a group that
may or may not be uh considered a
statistical outlier in a group of other
data is that what I'm understanding that
that was part of their expressed
concerns
right thank you Mr
chair I think something that was said is
sticking in my craw and that is I think
the applicant should have to
prove when they say they couldn't site a
landfill with that rule I would like to
see the evidence I would think this
committee should see the evidence in
print that they can prove that with the
numbers that we had previously that a
landfill could not be
cited thank
you
so that makes sense to me and um but I
wanted to to clarify something that I so
we started with one number I think it
was 10 to minus three and then we went
to 10 into minus5 but we started with 10
to minus three in the old rules is
that can you explain how we got to 10 to
minus
three I ask J Jamie Colby is um a
student of chomping at the bit there to
absolutely put me back in my place my
talk thank
you good morning for the record my name
is Jamie kby I'm supervisor of
engineering permitting in the solid
waste management Bureau at Dees um with
regards to the hydraulic conductivity
just be cautious there's a little bit of
confl it sounds to me like we're
conflating the sighting requirements
with the design requirements 804 is
about landfill sighting and that's where
you see the 10 the minus 3 805 is about
landfill design and that's where you see
the 10 Theus 4 or 10 Theus 5 so the 10
Theus 4 or the 10us 5 would be material
that they bring in to build a a stable
Foundation layer on top of the insitu
soils the 10 the minus three is what's
there naturally um what is in situ when
you go to choose a site great so I just
that talking to someone that actually
knows is
helpful thank
you that is there yes represent a
potential
so just a couple statements first 80% uh
86% of the state's underlay is Clay so I
just wanted that to be clear based upon
some other comments that was talked
about but Mount carbury right now as I
know passes actually every test in any
draft of the rules that are for Main and
10 to the minus 3
criteria for the natural site actually
is a hundred times weaker than Maine
currently so I think that's really
important since we're taking more than
50% of aate trash why do we want to be
the state that is weaker that has less
restrictions I don't than all of the
other surrounding ones when we would
like to not be 50% of out of state trash
here and I want to go back to um I would
like like a tracked version of all of
the private meetings that have taken
place while this is while this whole
process is has been going on so um that
the you know in the essence of
transparency that the agency puts that
out all of the private meetings we
haven't had a landfill application in 30
years and we're working on rules and if
we're writing rules that could help
someone that wants to build a landfill
ridiculous representive Jam thank you Mr
chairman uh and so to come back and I
appreciate the clarification thank you
very much about get I as a totally you
know not a scientist and that's an un
gross understatement trying to
understand uh the process thinking about
the undisturbed site so this is the site
as you find it right and then the
prepared or engineered site and and in
the current draft 1 time 10 the3rd for
the undisturbed site as you find it
right and 1 time 104 for the engineered
site right and there's again the October
draft had that at 10 to the neg 5th and
it's been brought back so my question
also has to do
with and this is a genuine question
based on lack of understanding of a lot
of these things why we wouldn't want the
the natural site to to be say 10 to the
ne4th
because it would seem to me that we're
talking about these landfills which we
have to have and we have to site
properly that we should only be looking
for the safest sites in the state to do
that so this idea that it's going to be
10 to the neg3 but we're going to bring
it up through Engineering also kind of
raises questions to me about what
happens if we have leaks or if we have
malfunctions uh there's some type of
malfunction in in the engineering work
that's done but if we're talking about
the the sites where we're going to put a
landfill it would seem to me that almost
by definition we should be looking for
the very
safest uh places in the state to do that
based on what is currently there so I'm
a little bit confused about why we would
even have this kind of process where
we're saying well the conditions can
don't have to be ideal on the natural
site but we'll kind of engineer it up to
a point where we think it's safe it
would seem to me that the site itself
should
already meet those conditions and then
you provide engineering that that
provides the extra levels of safety that
that we need to have so I don't know if
anyone can kind of talk me through that
I mean why would we why would we do that
instead of just demanding that the site
as it
stands meets the standards we want it to
meet well the sighting criteria are
essentially that that you need to meet
whatever they may be in the end you need
to meet those sighting criteria and I I
think as we've discussed here this
morning um
in a perfect world we just say it has to
be the tightest soils on the planet and
that's the only place you can build a
landfill but in practicality that would
eliminate all the sites so our job is to
figure out you know what what
provides efficient and effective level
of protection from from the standpoint
of sighting criteria that still leaves
some land available for development of
landfills and that's not an easy thing
but that's essentially what we're
struggling with right now I
um let me representative Murray one
second sure represent
Murray I'll yield to the member because
my question might not be a thank you
very much I I would just suggest that
I'm I'm not talking about finding the
most ideal circumstances uh conditions
on the planet but I am saying that we
should be only citing these in the most
ideal conditions that exist in the
state we would agree with
that okay represent Marine thank you Mr
chair um and while we're at it I guess
in in speaking to the potential uh
desire to see track changes within the
document as well I think that I that's
another yes from me um between the
proposed one in October and January a
question I did have was um some while
back we had did have a discussion in one
of the 800 sections about uh
notification in the event of a failure
or a leak and there was a discussion
around who gets notified and when um and
I think most of the discussion if I
remember correctly was around uh the
actual um it was onsite notification the
emergency system and I was we we had
asked a question several meetings ago
about whether or not there is a
coordinated uh Municipal communication
in the event of a failure or a leak or
any anything like that and I just wanted
to follow up with you all as to where
that had
gone where that goes I'm sure discussion
I don't
do remember that were we talking about
scada at the time I think so yeah um I
know that we took it I'm sorry leam
McKenna um administrator of the Sol was
management Bureau I know that we took
that down and I have to say I don't
remember where it's gone but it doesn't
mean that it's gone forever I know I
have it here um so I think what we're
going to go is is look back to make sure
that we were um addressing the concerns
of making sure that uh a larger audience
was notified was that that was that was
a gist okay got it that was my request
and I just I like I said in looking
through them I just did not see that so
if it's there great if not so many
moving Parts I'm gonna I'm gonna I'll
I'll make a note again just to make sure
thank you thank
you yeah Miss McKenzie if you could just
prenza so I'd like to understand what
the easiest way is to because you know I
have this document um all marked up with
you know comparing from October to
present to what we have and in questions
and um you know some of these things we
want to go back to what it was in
October so what is the best way for this
committee here to provide that
information um like there's some things
that you know some word changes that
were significant for example on page
three it says here um undisturbed inside
soils beneath the footprint so if
there's a
leak the footprint is completely moot by
definition so and of course you know
there can be spills that are outside the
footprint any time so there's just some
things that were maybe I don't know why
they were changed but that just don't
make sense and we want to go back to how
they were so how do we how do we make
that happen same thing with this
discussion of 10 to the3 to the four
five whatever how do we how do we put
our resources together and provide to
you where we would like things to go
back to how they were and give other
suggestions what's the best way to work
together on this well and I think you
know obviously the committee is is
autonomous and makes its own decisions
the committee as a whole or individual
members of the committee are certainly
at Liberty and invited to provide um
ideally in order to make sure that we
really understand your comment and and
and can try to address it written
comments or written notes about that and
that's something that you know it we
we've got a which I think is great an
ongoing dialogue with this subcommittee
which you know which we'll continue to
have at it at the committee's pleasure
um and you know I think maybe
practically speaking based on what I
talked about earlier where we do intend
to go back to the waste management
Council um at their February 15th
meeting um we will likely have uh you
know completed a lot of our work and
made some decisions about changing that
extent we want to make changes that we
would make you know we could plan to
come back to this subcommittee and and
give an update on that after that
happens if that's helpful um and then of
course you know again that that would
just mean that um we'd still be in the
process of getting an initial proposal
filed so the formal rulemaking process
you know either if it's right after the
15th may not have even started yet or
you know we in order to stay on schedule
here I think we will be filing our
initial Proposal with the officer
legislative Services um by uh the end of
February that's our schedule right now
but certainly any any the committee as a
whole if it chose or any committee
members certainly at Liberty and invited
and encouraged to provide their written
comments to the agency and would you
recommend that before you filed or after
you filed early and often s
wmb rules that's going to be the the the
main pipeline right to get to um you
know the rule writers to have all those
things gathered in writing that would be
the most helpful so thank you for asking
the question yeah I'll have that we'll
work together and get that to you right
away okay um any other questions
followup so I got a couple of takeaways
on this um first of
all uh if you could
provide um through myself to the
committee the track change
that the difference between the first
one and the second you know what the
changes have
been uh since the I mean prior to the 18
January um and then prior to the next
meeting if you could give us that what
changes have been made so so just so I'm
clear so it's it's $2 documents then
it's a it's a track changes document of
what was changed from the what we put
out in October 18th for comment to what
we filed correct um with the waste
management Council on the 18th yeah um
and
then prospectively ATT track changes
from what we filed on the 18th to what
we would present to the counc is that
feasible on the 15th I I'm getting I'm
getting a cross-eyed look so what's
feasible
I think so but I'm not sure I'm not
positive that we would have the October
to January 18th I'm certain we would
have it Forward we're gonna have to look
honestly let give us a moment and from
committee members is that if they take a
look and give us what they can give us
is that
reasonable yeah and going forward I
think it should always be that way if we
have to try CH okay uh and the second
thing is the request for a list of
meetings
um who who you know who we met with and
date and then I will look for a meeting
sometime between 15 February and the 1
of March does that make sense committee
members does that make
sense okay um and
then you know how it is when you get old
well I guess you don't know how it is
when you get old the so cobwebs Dustin
off when I was
a sophomore at West Point I took a class
called garbage that's what we call it I
I also took sewers I took but anyway
garbage was a waste management I was
environmental engineer major um who
would ever thought that 45 years later
I'd be sitting in a committee talking
about garbage um but the the cobwebs
dusted off this morning were that
uh we didn't in that class and there
were like eight of us we didn't
understand until we actually went to a
waste facility and so what I would
propose is that we set up a a discussion
at a waste treatment
facility and we could figure out the
details on that but then you know to to
meet there and
go come on in lady if you can just sit
and back that's fine
um I think we would get a much better
understanding of the process and the
system yes ma'am thank you Mr chair um I
think I am the only person who has tour
a Waste Management Facility so I would
be open to the members I think I yes it
was in a different lifetime but yes I I
think it would be insightful um for
those folks if they have not is there
any OB objecting to that uh
representative Davis you you good Penza
I've
already okay a great idea all right okay
so I I'll look at setting that up and
then we'll if you guys can meet us there
and just sort of get into the more
concrete understand of what we're
talking
about we'd certainly be happy to to are
you suggesting that there also would be
a meeting of the committee I I guess it
is a meeting if you're there but but um
or or just an actual tour of the
facility I think just a tour of the
facility just to deepen our
understanding of what physically is
going on sure on the ground I I think
that's a terrific idea and we'd be more
than happy to participate if the
committee would like us to okay and from
a timing perspective I was thinking
after the next committee meeting
sometime in March okay great do that
does that make sense to everyone yeah is
that Dragon Mr chair it would be noticed
still as a meeting even though it's a
meeting of the sub tour because have to
it right oh absolutely yeah gotcha we
just need to figure out the details and
get on a
counter okay and and just to uh be clear
is that a meeting that this committee
will organize or are you asking the
agency to organize that no I think we
can organize it but I would ask that a
representative from from your office be
there absolutely to um you know to
participate sure happy to do that okay
yeah thank you Mr I have to say in
another life time I worked at one of
these facilities
so I mean and that was you know before
even these rules were written so it was
a while ago uh but the other thing that
that I would like if possible for for a
future discussion is uh what and I'm not
sure you know what you can provide in
this regard but again some sense of you
know what percentage of the
state can or would be excluded by the
the stricter rules rules I mean we were
looking at
602 and uh I'm trying to remember the
other one
56 thank you uh somebody gave us a map
and you know it was I think it was the
the US Geological Survey right and we
talked about how that's not it was a
place to kind of be begin a discussion
roughly but any event if it's possible
because this is one of the concerns
you've heard a lot of US Express is that
uh you know we understand I certainly
understand the need to meet with the
people who operate these businesses but
I also want to have some kind of meat on
the bones I I I want to see evidence
that this claim that they're not going
to be able to site a landfill anywhere
in the state is valid uh if it is it is
but there has to be data if we're going
to take that claim at face value so any
information that we could get regarding
you know what percentage of the state at
least roughly would be excluded by the
draft we'll do what we can to try to
answer that question I mean the state is
not mapped at a granularity that allows
us that makes that easy to do it's uh
when you I mean if that were the case
then then folks would you know have a
whole list of sites they knew they could
site a landfill and the reality is you
don't really know whether you can site a
landfill somewhere until you go to that
site and you do some hydrogeological
testing in in in place in the field so I
I will we'll do our best to see what we
can provide for that but I I want to
manage expectations on that because I
think that's going to be a tall order
understandable but I you know they're
making these claims I'm assume based on
something so I understand that we don't
have that data
but I'm assuming that their claim is
based on some
data so I I would appreciate that yeah
thank you Mr chair yes ma'am may I it's
the applicants and the industries
responsibility to provide that data we
don't have to do it you don't have to do
it they should do it and do it to our
satisfaction because they're making the
claim seems simple to
me thank
you okay thank you and representative
Penza and I'll put this in the document
that we're GNA provide but I think I'm
just going to read this right from here
so based upon um um what representative
paskins just sent so the applicant shall
hire an independent Hydro geologist this
came from uh hp56 right at the
applicant's expense to estimate based
upon adequate and and representative
on-site field testing the seepage
velocity of groundwater in both uh
surface surficial geological deposits
and in Bedrock the maximum seepage
velocity shall be the highest rate
estimated for any test site in disposal
area the applicant shall hire an
independent Hydro Hy
hydrogeologist at the applicant's
expense that's that's what that really
needs to be in these rules here okay but
that's different than surveying the
entire State of New Hampshire to know
exactly what's below each square foot
that's that's for a very specific
defined site that's not the entire State
of New Hampshire
so understand that's what it says I
agree with it but it's not contextual to
what representative J was asking it's
not the same thing I understand okay um
so we got our do outs are there any
challenges and please as you go through
um working with us to get this
information appreciate open lines of
communication
certainly thank you thank you all right
uh subject to any other questions this
closes subcommittee meeting we got two
minutes to transition to the committee
meeting thank you very much thank you so
it
okay I'd like um our members to please
take their seats we're going to get
underway shortly as soon as the AV
out
seats
okay okay okay okay so sure good morning
everybody to environment agriculture
committee I'd like to begin this morning
by um having representative of smart
Allegiance Al to the United States of
America and to the rep for it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
all okay good
morning we have this morning
uh on our agenda uh two
presentations the first being um uh um
director whimet who would be giving us a
presentation um on contaminant
monitoring in our
landfills and uh then um we will have
some opportunity for some question and
uh Q&A and then at 11:00 we have the um
Plastics recycling presentation by
Patrick ker from the Plastics industry
Association so um I want to welcome
director whimet and his staff and um
have you take it away Welcome to our
committee this morning and thank you so
much for taking the time to do this
thank you madam chair for the record my
name is Mike winsat I serve as director
of the waste management division for the
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services uh we're pleased
to be with you here this morning um
joining me are um Jamie Colby who had up
our engineering and permitting section
in the solid waste management Bureau and
Jamie oor who uh is a hydrogeologist in
our haard waste remediation Bureau who
focuses on um landfill monitoring and um
uh groundwater release detection and
groundwater management permits for
landfills and I just really wanted to
introduce them they are the experts here
they're going to give a presentation to
you this morning probably lasts about 20
or 25 minutes it's a PowerPoint
presentation with some slides that I
think will be really helpful and um um
so I'm going to turn it over to them and
I'm going to sit down and um then we'll
we'll be certainly available to
entertain any questions that you might
have following the presentation so with
that I will uh turn it over to Jamie
thank
you thank you director good morning
thank and thank you for the opportunity
to present about New Hampshire's
landfill monitoring requirements for the
record my name is Jamie kby and I am
supervisor of the engineering and
permitting section in the solid waste
management Bureau at Dees
for a quick orientation most of us are
aware that there are six operating
Municipal Solid Waste landfills or MSW
landfills in New Hampshire in addition
there's one operating single lined
colash landfill and two unline landfills
that accept construction demolition
debris and bulky waste this slide shows
the six Active mssw landfills kind of
spread around the
state there are also more than 200
clothes some of which are lined but most
of which are unlined
effectively almost every municipality
has a
landfill line landfills and many of the
online landfills have not one but two
permits a solid waste permit and a
groundwater permit I'm going to spend a
few minutes talking about landfill
monitoring required under the solid
waste permit and then my colleague Jamie
oor will discuss the monitoring
requirements under a landfill's
groundwater
permit as a quick refresher when we
discuss whether a line a landfill is
lined or unlined we're talking about the
design of the landfill some landfills
have no liners that is there are unlined
landfills some landfills have a single
liner for example one geomembrane or
engineered plastic sheet along with
other materials that sit between the
waste and above the ground
surface a double Line Landfill has two
of these geomembrane Lin liners with
other materials as shown in the
simplified sketch on the slide in a
double lined landfill the space between
each liner is typically referred to as a
lee8 collection system or layer the lee8
collection system at a landfill is
monitored in multiple ways first there
is the physical element regarding the
quantities of leech eight the amount of
leech eight standing on the primary
liner is typically measured and recorded
daily the quantity of leech a collected
and trans reported offsite is measured
and recorded daily and lee8 flow rates
in the secondary collection system are
measured and recorded at least once per
week then there are the analytical
characteristics of leech eight lee8 from
the primary collection system is
analyzed three times per year for
contaminant concentrations and leate
from the secondary collection system is
analyzed once per year for contaminant
concentrations the data collected from
from the lee8 systems helps us look for
issues with the Integrity of the liner
systems for example elevated flows in
the secondary leic collection system May
liner let's follow the leap for a
moment recall that when a liquid passes
through a landfill's waste Mass it
leeches or extracts chemicals or
constituents from waste as these waste
break down
along with pasas these can include
organic compounds heavy metals chlorides
and nitrates leachate is a liquid
including any suspended components in
the liquid which is contacted or passed
through solid waste in short leate is
the byproduct of the landfilling
process as such the concentrations of
contaminants in leate are based on what
types and amounts of waste are placed in
a landfill and while the analytical
characteristics of leech a are tested
there are no standards against which to
compare the results of the leech a tests
the first point at which lee8
characteristics might be compared to a
standard is that a lee8 receiving
facility that is a wastewater treatment
plant wastewater treatment plant
operators ensure that the Wastewater
entering the facility in this case lee8
can be properly managed in accordance
with the design limitations of the plant
and be treated to meet the plant's
discharge permit limits if the
concentrations of contaminants in lee8
exceed the treatment plants acceptance
criteria the responsibility falls back
on the landfill permit to find a
wastewater treatment plant that can
accept the leachate or to treat the
leech eight at the landfill before
facility now let's head back to the
landfill for a minute it's important to
note that there are other ways of in
which we monitor landfills for example
gas probes are located around a landfill
in the soil similar to groundwater
monitoring Wells these probes are
checked quarterly for landfill gas if
landfill gas is migrating through the
ground and into these probes this might
indicate a problem with the landfill's
gas collection system or with the
landfill's liner
system and after a landfill is closed
these monitoring programs continue
leachate flow rates analytical
characteristics and quantities continue
to be measured and recorded monitoring
is still performed to check for landfill
gas migration and the landfill undergo
semiannual inspections to check the
Integrity of the capping system and
other components of the landfill
system I think it's important to pause
here for a moment to consider recall
that landfills are engineered waste
containment systems they are designed by
and construction is overseen by licensed
Professional Engineers and at least
least once per year if not more often
the monitoring data is reviewed by
licensed professionals including de's
licensed professionals when issues or
irregularities come up in the monitoring
data these qualified licensed
professionals review and discuss and
work to identify and resolve the issue
with that I'm going to actually stop
here and turn it over to my colleague
Jamie oor who is himself a licensed
professional geologist and who will be
thank you Jamie for the record my name
is James oor I'm a supervisor of the
groundwater permitting and Remediation
subsection and the Hazardous Waste
remediation Bureau within the waste
management division obviously our group
has the responsibility of overseeing
groundwater permitting at landfills as
my colleague discussed there are two
basic landfill construction types in New
Hampshire lined and unlined with each of
those comes specific groundwater
monitoring permit that is associated
with it online landfills will have
groundwater management permits
associated with them those are landfills
without a liner beneath the waist lined
landfills active and closed would have
groundwater release detection permits
associated with them now there are some
facilities in the state that have both
permits combined into one in fact three
out of the operating six landfills in
New Hampshire have both combined
groundwater release detection and ground
management
permits there are a lot of commonalities
between the two permit types each permit
type uh will prescribe a a program for
periodic groundwater
monitoring they'll also provide for
groundwater remediation as outlined
within the permit structure they'll
specify performance standards for those
remedies and describe procedures for
performing site investigations and
implementing any necessary corrective
actions just for reference uh these
permits aren't necessarily exclusive to
landfills in fact there have been
thousands of sites administered by Dees
under groundwater
specifics groundwater management permits
will designate groundwater management
zones areas where contaminate
concentrations in groundw have been
identified and are known to be above
some kind of above ambient groundwater
quality standards
and as such are required to be monitored
regularly a groundwater management
permit controls the use of groundwater
within a groundwater management Zone if
there happens to be a water supply
within that zone it would be regular
regularly monitored to assure compliance
with State
regulation the permit will also require
the implementation of measures to
restore groundwater quality within the
groundwater management zone so that it
meets the criteria of EnV
o600 the ambient groundwater quality
standard ards or
aqs it will also require the evaluation
of the effectiveness of any remedial
measures taken to restore that groundw
quality now on to groundwater release
detection permits these are permits
associated with our active and inactive
lined
facilities groundwater release detection
permits established detection monitoring
during the active life of the facility
during any closure activities and Beyond
past closure so in effect uh groundwater
release detection permit will be on the
site from its Inception when it's being
operated and on through closure to
confirm the functioning of the
containment system that my colleague Des
described groundwater release detection
permits require monitoring for early
detection of impacts associated with a
facility based on comparison to
background statistical deviations from
background data and historic Trends May
Sign May signify an exceedance the
permits require a 10-day notification to
Dees if there are exceedences of these
background
conditions exceedences May trigger
what's called assessment monitoring
which is accelerated and expanded
monitoring outside of the normal
schedule of the
permit exceedences can also require a
corrective action plan be submitted to
achieve compliance with the background
conditions at the location a corrective
action plan is just that it's a plan to
rec correct those issues that are
causing the exceedences of
background
I'm sorry I forgot to advance that slide
for release detection have to forgive
me so back to some more
commonalities um each groundwater permit
type will require monitoring for
compliance at various locations around
the landfill that'll include monitoring
Wells that are specifically designed and
located to monitor the facilities at at
at around the landfill base if you will
excuse me it also in include monitoring
of water supply if they happen to be
available groundwater
seeps as well as surface water any
locations that might help inform the
conceptual site model the conceptual
site model is our basic understanding of
the site how it relates to the the
physical uh physical location around it
it's geohydrology as
well the permit will have analytical
requirements for samples collected from
these monitering points samples are
required to be analyzed by certified
Laboratories the landfills are required
to analyze for what are called landfill
leate indicator parameters as my
colleague discussed the liquid derived
from waste is considered leachate and it
contains the breakdown components of the
waste so a broad spectrum of various
contaminants and compounds are available
to be monitored for we call them
landfill lee8 indicator parameters they
can include compounds such as chloride
nitrate
sulfite various Metals such as Arsenic
and magnes
volatile organic compounds such as
Benzene and tuline and solvents such as
pce and
tce recently we have been requiring
monitoring of contaminants of emerging
concern those items such as 14 dioxane
and pasas or per and polyfloral
substances pfoa and pfos these are
compounds that have been in commercial
and Industrial use for over 50 to 60
perhaps 70 years however until recently
we didn't know about them we didn't have
the analytical ability to analyze for
them at low enough concentrations or
perhaps we didn't have the awareness of
their toxical impacts additional
requirements to monitor for these
emerging contaminants have been added to
our groundwater permits within the last
seven
years for reference until recently a
majority of the concentrations for
contaminants were measured in the parts
per billion
range now with these added contaminants
of emerging concern we are measuring
meur in for concentrations in the parts
per trillion range so a thousand times
less just for reference from a spatial
component and get your mind around it a
little bit a part per billion would be
equal to one drop of ink in a 10,000
gallon swimming pool so a good siiz
backyard swimming pool one part per
trillion would be the equivalent of a
drop within 20 olympic size swimming
pools which are over 600,000 gallons so
an enormous difference between those
two the permits also require a require a
basic monitoring frequency how often the
site and locations and specific Wells
are monitored for how often they monitor
for the compound compounds we discussed
previously uh for a for a point of
reference the active Municipal Solid
Waste landfills in New Hampshire are
sampled at least two if not three times
a year they can also be sampled Beyond
those as needed um within the release
detection monitoring rules you can have
accelerated monitoring like I discussed
previously
there are two basic submittal types
within per groundw permits you have data
transmittals that are essentially just
that a submittal of the data with a
little added extra couple of extra
pieces they are due to be submitted to
us within 45 days of the sampling event
there are also periodic summary reports
which are required by permit summary
reports provide an overview of the work
performed since the last time a summary
report was submitted it would include a
description of the type and frequency of
monitoring and the activities associated
with them and provide any updates to the
conceptual site model it'll also include
conclusions and recommendations provided
by the licensed professional submitting
the
report the summary report would include
a tabular and graphical summary of the
results and Trends in comparison to
Historic data and in support of the
conclusions and recommendations that the
consultant may have updated groundw flow
maps and any analytical results that
hadn't been previous submitted
previously submitted would be included
as well
summary reports are required to be dated
signed and stamped by New Hampshire
licensed professional geologists or
Professional
Engineers also
included in sumary reports is the um
excuse me is a schedule for submitting
those summary reports uh for instance
active Municipal Solid Waste landfills
will sum will submit summary reports
annually an older online landfill that
maybe is monitored at a less frequent
rate maybe maybe submits a summmer
report every other year or maybe every
third year depending on that conceptual
site model we
discussed as a point of reference when
these submittal are transmitted to Dees
they're reviewed by Dees staff that are
assigned to these projects they are also
licensed professionals Dees responses to
any of these Subs would also be reviewed
by at least one if not two more licensed
professional geologists or Professional
Engineers now lastly uh in relation to
groundwater permits each permit type are
in in effect for a 5-year period and are
subject to Renewal if the permit expires
prior to Renewal the permit continues to
be fully responsible for those
conditions outlined within the permit
including monitoring reporting and any
corrective actions that might be
outlined
within renewals for groundwater permits
will also include many of the same
elements of a summary report just
expanded out over 5year period of time
and in comparison to Historic results
those renewals are also prepared by
licensed
professionals one common question we get
in regards to how long groundwater is
being one common question we get is how
long groundwater will be required to be
sampled and monitored at
landfills for landfills groundwater
quality monitoring is required until the
waste mass is no longer a potential
source of contamination so there are
essentially two ways for that to happen
happen one would be the landfill would
be dug up removed and disposed of
somewhere else it actually has happened
um historically uh 20 years ago there
were several landfills that were dug up
removed and disposed of Elsewhere has
not happened recently um majority of the
municipal majority of the landfills in
New Hampshire are municipally owned and
obviously they're not going to have the
money to throw around for something like
that the other Avenue for groundwater to
be ceased groundwater monitoring to be
ceased at a landfill would be for the
Pere to undertake an investigation to
show that the waste within the landfill
has completely broken down now that has
not happened and reason being as we know
it takes quite a while for Waste to
break down sometimes hundreds if not
thousands of years if you look at any of
the science journals and see how long it
takes plastic to break down it it takes
an exceptionally long time so
essentially unless someone digs up a
landfill and removes it groundwater
monitoring will exist at landf fills in
perpetuity
time wanted to thank you uh for the
opportunity my apologies for not
advancing slides I probably should have
thrown the the laptop at my compatriot
here as I was speaking we can get you
copies of these um obviously uh if
needed uh we are available for questions
much thank you very much I appreciate
that
um I I'm interested to know
excuse me you talked about corrective
action
plans how many corrective action plans
does the department have active
now and do those plans have any kind of
deadlines associated with
them that's a very good question um
corrective action plans will come and go
over time we have had historically some
very significant corrective action plans
um we have at at least one that I'm
aware of at one of the six landfills um
we've had some others that have
um perhaps just finished within the last
couple years uh corrective action plan
could be something small scale related
to uh minor operational issue uh or it
could be something larger scale that
will incorporate both the monitoring
that is undertaken as part of the
groundwater permits but also will have
relationship to the solid waste
management bureau's execution uh at
landfills as well well groundwater very
much could be the first indicator of an
issue at a site and so the assessment
monitoring can help point to the issue
if there is one if there is found out to
be an issue by monitoring those landfill
lee8 indicator parameters that broad
swath um we may be able to point to uh
the issue directly or we might have to
cause and force more investigation of
that through the corrective action plan
process um sometimes it's very obvious
as to what the issue is sometimes it
takes a little bit of uh in-depth
investigation and um we're lucky that we
work so closely with a solid waste
management Bureau in that we sometimes
are able to say hey we think we have an
issue do you know anything so um but at
this time I believe we only have one
corrective action plan in
place and and for when you're doing
monitoring on these various
sites who's actually doing the
monitoring is some of it being done
third party uh some of it being done by
the department some of it being done by
the landfill operator who who's doing
the monitoring that's an excellent
question thank you U the monitoring
itself is being conducted by the
licensed professional that is hired by
the perite so the perite is typically
the landowner the landfill operator uh
the licensed professional will do the
monitoring and the sampling submit those
results to us as part of those submittal
that I discussed we review those uh and
consider their comments and
recommendations um sampling is
prescribed at a certain uh certain rate
uh as I discussed um we typically don't
do sampling of our own um as far as uh
General monitoring is concerned we do
have the ability at times uh if there is
a a landfill that doesn't have a
responsibility responsible party
associated with it or a Pere associated
um perhaps passed away if you will and
so we have had the ability at times to
send out the MTB sampling team to be
able to look at Residential Water
Supplies that might be a risk nearby but
it's a very rare situation that we have
to do do do you as a department
recommend who
the the parties are that are going to do
you recommend to the um landfill owner
who would he use to do the testing or do
you just let them pick whoever uh no we
we would essentially let them pick
whomever um we do get questions from
time to time as to you know uh maybe if
it's a small online landfill run owned
by a municipality and and they're trying
to look to change who might be doing
their work for them they may ask us and
we can recommend a long list of
qualified Consultants but each of them
need to be at least the folks who are
submitting those reports to us need to
be licensed professional geologists or
Professional Engineers so we wouldn't
specifically say who you should and
shouldn't use
no representative Murray thank you madam
chair and just uh for clarification and
followup those um individuals must be
licensed with the state of New Hampshire
correct yes you are correct they need to
be New Hampshire licensed professional
Engineers represent dsy
oh sfus first sorry I didn't see her um
yes good morning um I would for the
record like to have a copy of the slides
I was wondering if you could speak to
um the condition of the C landfill I
know it's kind of probably blindsiding
you but this committee some five or six
years ago found the kok landfill to be
an imminent Hazard as that legislation
went on it was killed but um there was a
significant cancer cluster around the
COK landfill and I was just wondering if
you could speak about
that I'm not sure if maybe the director
can speak to the C landfill as it uh
falls under a different program than
ours right for the record Mike wiat hire
Dees thank you representative for that
question so yes the the coka landfill is
a um super fund npl site that we do
manage under our federal sites program
and actually very recently um at the end
of this calendar past calendar year we
issued a report um that addresses those
questions and and basically gives an
update to the work that's been going on
to evaluate drinking water quality in
the area and groundwater quality impacts
of the facility so I would direct you to
that and following this meeting um when
I get back to the office I'll make sure
that we send you a copy of that with
electronic copy of that represent Duty
uh yes thank you madam chair thank you
um when we're talking about leate what
kind of quantities are we talking about
and when you talk about a system for
collecting it is it collected in pipes
that were designed into the landfill um
how does that whole system
work thank you representative for the
question um quantities I don't honestly
recall off top my head uh at a landfill
it can vary by year depends a lot on
rainfall um and different factors you
know it could be somewhere between two
million gallons a year and five million
gallons a year depending on sizes that's
that's all ballpark um with regards to
the lee8 management systems yes they do
involve a lot of piping um so in the
landfill liner system themselves there's
a combination of piping and free
draining sand and some geosynthetic
layers that encourage the flow of of the
lee8 through the system so that it can
be collected everything slopes down to a
collection sump and then it's um pumped
out of the bottom of the landfill up
pipes to the ground surface where it
enters additional piping systems and
then it moves into a tank storage system
um or it could move more directly into
pipes so in that go to a wastewater
treatment facility half the landfills
are directly piped to a wastewater
treatment facility half of the six the
the other half of the six have to truck
um the leech eight if I remember it's
roughly that
split um so and those systems are
designed they are required to be
designed to be chemically compatible
with leech 8 um try and get as much
longevity as we can out of those
engineered Lee collection and
containment
systems followup represent Murray uh
thank you madam chair um so while we're
on the subject of uh lee8 uh I think you
showed a slide of of the lee8 the truck
and then it going to a treatment
facility but we also noted that there
are some entities that have treatment on
site correct and then it gets treated on
site and
perhaps goes elsewhere afterward it does
it then go somewhere else on on the
track but to that point I guess I'm
asking is in the design
criteria is that up to the individual um
entity to decide whether or not they're
putting that sort of reverse osmosis
system or leate treatment system on on
site thank you for the question it's a
good question so there is one landfill
in the state that has elected to treat
onsite their leech a and what what
happens at their plant this is very
generalized um their on-site treatment
plant the leech a comes in it it goes
through a processing system part of it
is piped to a wastewater treatment
facility nearby the other portion of it
is trucked to different wastewater
treatment facilities so theirs is
actually a split system in that in that
manner
um and in terms of those plants what's
designed how they choose to treat that's
that's the Peres Choice what they're
trying to do is they're trying to meet
the acceptance criteria for a wastewater
treatment receiving
facility representative Bixby yes thank
you for taking my question so
um what is so the lee8 goes to a
wastewater treatment plant except in the
case of Rochester where it's
pre-treated and then it goes to one but
uh what is the fate of the contaminants
in the
leachate uh at the wastewater treatment
plant does it end up in biosolids is
there a way to uh keep them ex um
separated from the
biosolids so I'm going to confess that's
not my area of expertise I'm not a
Wastewater expert um as a general matter
the the stream is mingled in with the
other Wastewater stream so leeche gets
mixed in with all the other waste Waters
that come into the plant um and so it's
not necessarily separately managed or
processed at that plant so the
contaminants would you
know not my expertise some would be
broken down into constituent Parts some
would end up in the biosolids or the
sledges some might end up in the
discharge um at a lower level so
so that if you know if you need need
follow-up information we'd have to reach
out to the appropriate people at Dees
for that on Wastewater plants just I
want to ask a question following that
you know
in since you're you are monitoring the
Lee hates and and what the the
composition of the
leeat are you noticing any Trends um
from site to site or site
specific um are the different compounds
certain compounds rising and others
going down um do you
lee8 there can be Trends in the lee8
um contaminant concentrations chemical
constituents uh but
we don't have that data compiled in a
fashion that trends like that that's
something that we're evaluating for
propos R change so that Trend analysis
we don't have a lot compiled on trending
one thing that we will see for example
um goes back to what if there's an issue
with the liner systems you know if
there's a lot of dilution it means we
might have a storm water problem storm
water's getting into leech a system so
so there is we do keep an eye on what
the concentrations are but we don't have
it actually trended out like in a plot
right
now so with and also as you're
monitoring the
leeet what happens when you see some
exceedances for thresholds that you have
for certain um certain contaminants in
there what do you do you have to do
anything different with that so there
aren't again it goes back to that idea
that leech a is is simply a byproduct of
the waste uh landfilling process so
there's not a standard to compare it to
so there wouldn't be an exceedence of
any particular standard
um in in that context um you know the
the landfill permites keep an eye on the
waste that they choose to dispose of in
the landfill because they know it can
have an effect on their leee quality and
then that could cause them difficulty
successfully finding a wastewater
treatment plant to take the material um
but there's not a specific there's not a
standard to compare it
against okay uh representative Bixby
yeah so is a leech is the volume of the
leachate um largely um due to liquids
that are in the disposed trash or is it
due to uh a combination of that and
precipitation yeah you know I don't have
a specific breakdown regarding what
amount comes out of the waste itself and
what amounts from precipitation landfill
permites are required to um operate the
landfill in a manner that controls to
the greatest extent practicable the
generation of leech eight so they are
striving they cover the waist at the end
of each operating day they they um put
on interim cover in areas they're not
going to work in for a while so they are
trying to minim minimize the generation
of leech a to the extent they can but I
don't have a specific breakdown on how
much is out of the waste itself and how
much might be from
precipitation represent saitis and then
represent Murray um I was just wondering
um about the of
biosolids um in um in relation to the
forever chemicals pest um because I'm
I'm concerned that how much is going to
be put on agricultur land and so I was
wondering if you could share anything
about
that um I appreciate the question
representative the fate of biosolids is
really um um with our Wastewater program
they deal with land application of
biosolid agricultural use um under the
under the regulations under the law
biosolids or sledges from wastewater
treatment plants only become Solid Waste
when they are disposed of at a solid
waste facility so if a landfill receives
sludge it's a solid waste it gets
disposed in the landfill um but sludges
or biosolids that go to places other
than landfills or other than disposal
would be something man managed by our
Wastewater
program representive Murray thank you
madam chair and I and I apologize for
going back a little bit to leate but I
did want to clarify one one thing if you
could for me um it's my understanding
that leate can be both in liquid form
and solid form and like a l cake of some
that I hadn't quite heard that um it
might be that some of the treatment
processes you end up kind of if you're
talking about a leech a cake it's
probably more like a like a sludge is is
what I'm leaning towards are solids that
are pulled out of the lee8 um as it's
treated I'm not overly familiar with
with what you're talking about um but I
would speculate that's kind of the the
situation is when they go through
certain treatment processes if they pull
out those suspended solids that might
create a
cake represent
Duty thank you madam chair so let me
understand we have what three or four um
privately owned landfills I think maybe
the there's two landfills that are owned
by municipalities maybe Nash Lebanon I
think that's pretty close and it doesn't
really matter but and and so if you're a
private landfill
50% in the state of New Hampshire comes
from outof State uh it's it's outof
state waste um and so this can contain p
and all all other kinds of um uh
waste products this goes into the
lee8 and then a wastewater treatment
facility that is paid for by um
taxpayers kind of picks up the tab to
take this water and I can't I mean and
and is it processed to the point that is
pure enough to then I'm thinking about
nashan going back in to the miramac
river um I'm I'm just a little
concerned and confused about um how
clean this is you know when it gets to
the um to the Wastewater facility and if
if there's p in it and we know pasas is
the forever chemical then the Wastewater
system is not going to be able to treat
it then it's going to go into the
miramac river I'm a little confused
about that can you explain that to me
sure I can thank you representative I
can try and elaborate a little little
bit um so there actually there are three
public landfills or or sort of uh Mount
carbury by the solid waste District NASA
and Lebanon are the three public if you
will and then three private uh oh no
there are four public sorry Conway is
also got a a public landfill so there
are only two private landfills in New
Hampshire privately owned um with
regards
they have to manage what they receive as
waste streams I'm sure they charge a fee
um per gallon it wouldn't surprise me at
all um I presume that's what happens
unless it's a municipal landfill and
then I'm sure they have some internal
budgeting um so it's my understanding
that they would you know private
landfills would certainly pay for
disposal of leee just like we all pay
for disposal our trash um and the waste
water treatment plant they have now
you're talking about the Clean Water Act
and their discharge permits into the
river so they have to meet certain
standards again not my expertise um but
I think it's important to understand
that and part of why I brought it up in
the presentation it's important to
understand that leeche goes to treatment
plants it's treated at those plants and
it has to meet a discharge limit out of
those plants um those
facilities so that's a Clean Water Act
that's a different permit required um
and we've moved away from landfills at
that
Penza so could we get a um information
from the agency of where um public
private where all that lee8 is going so
when it leaves a landfill where where
where it's being treated can we get that
information uh I think we can yes they
are supposed to report to us we can um
pull up some reports and identify where
exactly they're
shipping so basically you guys said that
you you're not tracking any of the leech
a
correct you said you don't have any data
over Trends or
time we have the data um but we have not
compiled a recent Trend analysis on um
the quality of the lee8 like for example
using the lee8 indicator parameters we
have actually plotted it up um recently
so what about have you trended uh
volume periodically we will check volume
Trends um we've done some of that again
it's not hasn't been updated within the
last six months to a year so if I asked
for 10 years of leech eight from every
one of the landfills you wouldn't have
that data we have the data but it's not
necessarily compiled into like an Excel
spreadsheet the data exists in the
record for each facility um and that can
be reviewed either through one stop or
um make a a right to no file review
request and we can provide that okay so
my last question has to do with the
monitoring wells in the groundwater
quality so are those in a trend so let's
say if we just look at one of the a one
landfill so let's say what we going to
talk about Rochester I'm in Rochester so
do we have um every bit of information
in a trend for as long as that um
landfill has been in existence when
something you know tested hot or
whatever do we have all of that all of
that data is included within the summary
reports and the and the permit renewal
uh submitt that we they that are
submitted by the facilities uh certain
compounds that are of concern or uh that
are being tracked closely will have
Trend analysis data associated with them
specifically for the turn key facility
um a majority a majority of the
compounds the landfill le8 indicator
parameters that we discussed are plotted
tracked and trended within those sumary
reports
yes okay um representative ger thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question uh if I remember correctly uh
in one of the slides you were talking
about you said that typically the
landfill sites are are tested twice a
year but they can be tested more
requests yeah so each facility in each
uh landfill has a permit that's specific
to that location and and the frequencies
sometimes are tailored off of our
understanding of a site for example an
unline landfill might have been
monitored for the last 20 or 30 years we
have a tremendous amount of data that
might uh point in a certain direction of
saying well if we sample in the spring
we'll have the highest concentrations of
some kind of of compounds now for active
landfills we're going to be monitoring
them and have them required to be
monitored on a more frequent basis to
confirm that the uh containment systems
are working uh majority of our active
landfills are monitored and sampled
three times a year um we can accelerate
and require sampling um on an intern
basis in between them if there is some
exceedence of a background condition um
a compound ends up being higher
concentration we could ask for
confirmation um we can require
assessment monitoring to make sure that
there isn't something going on at the at
the facility in the leee management
system that's compromised in some way so
yes follow followup sure thank you and
so I'm wondering about what conditions
have to exist or you kind of compel you
to ask for uh model for testing outside
of you know the the the the terms and
I'm thinking about I think a lot of us
are thinking about concern about uh the
levels of Pas for example in the AMC and
concerns about you know is that because
of an underlying site that's been there
for a long time is that perhaps related
to uh a problem with with the landfill
so uh again under what conditions do you
decide that it it's important to ask for
an accelerated testing uh
scheme with the release detection World
um and those permits it simply could be
an exceedence of background condition on
a onetime one shot one shot piece um if
if we see something like that in a
release detection permit and there is an
exceedance of uh some compound let's say
a past compound um actually not past
that's not something we have a long
enough history of we may be asking for
that anyway um if we had some kind of
Benzene compound that was detected for
the first time in a long time in a while
we would say let's let's have you go out
and and monitor that and confirm that
detection is that not something some
kind of Remnant or laboratory
contamination of some kind if it is
confirmed and we see some kind of upward
Trend we'd end up in that accelerated
assessment monitoring phase but we'd
also be looking at that longer wider
swath of landfill Le indicator
parameters to see if there are other
compounds that are also on an upward
trend of some kind landfill Li isn't
going to contain just one compound so
when we look at that we depend on that
larger swath now in instances of half of
our Municipal uh Solid Waste landfills
there are online landfills associated
with them they bring in their own set of
contamination issues and add a baseline
or noise if you will to the data that we
see so in that case we look at those
individual Wells and their individual
histories related to those landfill e
indicator parameters and look again at
those Trends do we see multiple things
going upward when they've been steady or
declining previously and in those cases
we would ask for and perhaps require
some kind of assessment monitoring or on
the other side because it's a dual type
permit at this location we could ask for
some kind of supplemental site
investigation some kind of more
intrusive investigation to see okay
what's going on
here thank you thank you
repr yes so uh there's a list of uh
compounds that you test lee8 for that um
ranging from well vola organic compounds
to Bast Etc uh and but uh that can't be
an exhaustive list of everything that's
in the lee8 so how do you track those do
you do do you have any method for
tracking the UN unidentified compounds
leite in in regards to analytic
components there aren't a lot of
analytical tests that we receive that
would have unidentified compounds that
was something that tentatively
tentatively tentative tentatively
tentatively excuse me tentatively
identified compounds was something that
we used to use a lot when we were
looking at petroleum sites because you'd
have this large large swath of petroleum
compounds that might be looked at and
then there's all this kind of mush at
the end that we really don't know what
it is if in the if in a landfill case we
were to see some issues like that um I'm
not sure we'd actually see it in the
laboratory anymore however um we would
require additional sampling an expanded
list of some kind uh for for example
pasas we regulate four pasas compounds
in the state right now pfoa
pfos pfhxs PF and
pfna and so some some sites will only
send us the results for those four
compounds some other sites will send us
the much a much longer list and
so that expanded list is is kind of a
request
uh more so because the ambient
groundwater quality standards are set
for a certain set of
compounds I have a question before you
so on the dees website there's a um
application there that you can visually
see where there are places that are
being monitored they are indicated by
green dots and yellow dots and red dots
okay um and I don't know if everybody's
familiar with with this tool or not
but what what constitutes first of all
how often is that updated and secondly
um what constitutes movement from one
color to the next are you you you're
looking at just specific compounds or an
overall measurement or any one
particular exceedence H how does that
can you explain that to me I think the
map you're referring to is our past
mapper that we've had out in the public
for several years that's
um that's populated on a volunteer basis
or as requested by Dees not all it's not
a requirement of our submittals
unfortunately at this time um a lot of
the data we've been actually I've been
very impressed in looking at what we've
been able to get from landfills um on
this as requested basis as I said most
of the sites most of the landfills in
New Hampshire are municipally owned and
Consultants will charge a little bit
more to say oh yeah we'll update that
the dees for you so there's a tremendous
amount of information there U many of
it's landfills a lot of it is also other
sites as well but I would caution that
that's not everything that we may have
on P now in regards to the color coding
components um it is p as a whole as I
understand it there is a legend that you
can pull down off to the side um that
can tell you exactly what the standards
are I I have to confess I can't remember
what the numbers are I know at one point
they were in comparison to our current
aqs but I think they might also have
some component of the former uh MCL of
70 uh back when we first started
discovering pasas in 20 well discovering
it in New Hampshire in 2017 2018 um in
regards to how often it's updated I
believe it's updated as data comes in
for a while it was being done um on a
somewhat regular schedule but I'm I'm
not familiar enough to know how much or
how quickly it was done if it was done
on a monthly basis or a quarterly basis
and what does the department do um when
there's a red dot on there I mean is
there is there some something that the
uh landowner the landfill owner has to
comply with in order to show that
they're trying to make that red dot go
back to yellow or green so that so the
the Red Dot is the backend things of
what you see with the data the Red Dot
for us would signify data that's come in
through the summer reports of data
transmittals there might be some kind of
action item re related to those
locations they may just be locations
that are exceptionally close to a
landfill where it's a known exceedance
where some corrective action plan might
be undertaken occasionally we'll have a
uh we'll have exceedances at a a
boundary well so I mentioned groundwater
management zones previously groundwater
management zone is intended to be the
full area that ground is contaminate
above the ambient groundwater quality
standard with the Advent of things like
past and lower standards for arsenic and
manganes some of these groundwater
management zones have had to grow
additional investigations been required
into them because some well at the very
very downg gradient point of it a
compliance well if you will might be
showing exceedances of something that
either wasn't tested for before because
we didn't have the ability or the
standard might have changed so in those
cases Dees will direct the permit e and
their consultant as a consequence to
perhaps do uh some kind of additional
investigation our primary and first
concern is to make sure that people are
drinking clean water and so one of the
first steps we'll do when we're looking
at expanding or investing in a gmz
compliance issue is are there any
drinking water supplies near mine and if
so um the Consultants will request to
have to be able to sample those drinking
water supply locations um most folks are
pretty uh pretty accommodating some are
not um they don't want to have their
sample uh their water sampled but in
many cases they do and so there'll be
some additional um data that may come
from that so we can assure that also uh
there might be additional site
investigation and additional monitoring
Wells to make sure um we have that full
compliance area mapped now when we look
at some of this data as well we might be
able to reach out to our our Associates
in the solid waste management Bureau and
say hey we have these detections is
something changed at the landfill's
operation if it's a closed landfill
maybe they have some kind of issue with
their cap or storm water maintenance if
it's an active landfill if we think
about release detection and maybe some
kind of leech a management issue so we
communicate back and forth rather
extensively okay thank you uh
representative Murray thank you madam
chair um thanks for taking my question
um so just to clarify uh you indicated I
think what uh uh the chair was speaking
about was the map around drinking water
sample testing across the state um and
just so that I'm clear your stating that
you believe the um there are data there
um that still exhibit um the 70 MCL but
we are well past that as a state is that
what I heard you saying we're somewhere
in the 15 yes yes I it's the color
coding I can't recall off the top of my
head if we had more time I could pull it
up on my laptop and we could play around
and look at dots um but I can get back
to you on that and I can walk walk you
through exactly how to pull that up when
we're looking at the data on those pages
thank you and then follow up if I may uh
quickly because we're running out of
time yep and then I think to uh
representative bixby's point I think the
question that I had was just um
regarding unidentified pases yet we know
that that is changing so to his point
unidentified um contaminants could they
possibly include things like pases that
are not reported on or required to be
reported
on uh yes yes I mean when we think about
what we were sampling for it landfills
before 2016 when pasas came on board P
was there we just didn't have the
ability to analyze for it it's been in
the waste mass and waste streams for 50
60 70 years that's why we see it at
these online landfills we just didn't
have the ability to to see it uh based
on technology okay um one last quick
question or well I could two just two
last questions uh representative Howard
and then representative Penza thank you
madam chair and thanks for answering the
question I heard you say a couple of
times that there were no standards and
no comparable standards but you talk
about exceedances doeses that mean that
um that the each each land landfill site
is on its own comparison or
or no that's thank you representative
for the question thank you for asking
for clarification because I was thinking
about that remember we're talking about
two different permits so under the solid
waste permit there is no standard that
you compare lee8 against so byproduct of
the landfilling process it's a liquid
that comes out of the waste system when
we talk about exceedences what Jamie's
talking about is relative to the
groundwater permit if lee8 shows up in
the groundwater you can have exceedances
of certain groundwater quality standards
so that's an important distinction the
two different
permits does that help okay thank you
representative
Penza So based upon all of this and our
committee has received a lot of
information of course in regards with
the landfill in Bethlehem I'd like to
understand um specifically what is the
Bethlehem for the North Country
Environmental Services lfi NCS yes yes
from a groundwater perspective correct
okay um the NCS landfill has a joint
permit both release detection and
groundwater management permit it has an
unline had an online landfill associated
with it that was removed in the
1990s at that time it was removed and
replaced and placed into the existing
Line Landfill sections uh the area uh in
which the landfill existed is in within
a groundwater management zone so there
are known exceedances of ambient grer
quality standards at that location at
the time the landfill was removed there
were very high numbers of and
concentrations of those compounds we
were looking for at those times um and
as as the landfill was REM moved and
during the 20 years since or plus uh
those concentrations have moved moved
downward and improved immensely um
residual contamination at the at the
site has continued to be uh there also
within the groundwater but also within
soils and interstitial spaces that are
unable to be uh removed if you will and
as such um there are some residual
impacts that remain the residual imp PS
we see today are largely pasas and low
lower numbers of 14 dioxane in some
cases numbers in which in in in
reference to 14 oxane specifically are
below the standard that were in place uh
back in 2016 I believe we went from
three to
32 um pfas obviously wasn't monitored
for until U 2016 2017 at the location we
see past numbers there some of them are
in exceedence of hqs standards in which
that's the area in which we are
comparing to for the groundwater
management Zone those numbers are are
are significant however when we monitor
out and we look at the monitoring that's
being done at the compliant sections of
the groundwater management Zone uh the
concentrations drop off to below
standards so at this time it's
maintaining compliance now there is an
expanded site investigation that is
being required in the area in which that
is Dow gradient of the landfill this
area has also been heavily used um for
lee8 management purposes with a history
of of issues that have been related
there and and investigated however we
have I believe a November 7th letter
that has been put out that's requiring
additional site investigation of those
areas additional monitoring points um to
help inform and update that pyc
conceptual model I was discussing before
conceptual models are not static they're
meant to grow and under and improve as
we uh learn more about a site and as
such that's what our request is at this
time okay thank you I'm going to have to
um end our question answer time now and
um I want to thank the department for
coming before us today with this
presentation and being so gracious to
answer um some of our questions all of
our questions and I appreciate it and um
guess uh all I can say is thank you
again and uh have a great rest of the
day thank you very much right thank
you now um we have the U pleasure of
welcoming
um Patrick creger from the Plastics
industry
Association who will be giving us a
presentation on Plastics
Recycling and we'd like to very much
morning give give you a moment to set up
in
I also wanted to remind our our
uh committee that I have a sympathy card
for Matt kulan if you'd like to sign it
if you haven't signed it
already pass it to
okay
know
all
right well welcome Mr creger and I
really appreciate you coming to our
committee to uh give us
some uh information and educate us about
what's going on in the Plastics industry
and uh some good information about
Plastics Recycling and so forth
so thank you for coming and and take it
away you got you gotta press the button
so there you go red button is talking
perfect red button good morning
everybody thank you for inviting me I'm
really excited to be here today um I've
never been to New Hampshire and they
tell me January is the best time to
come this was wonderful for me um my
name is Patrick creger I'm the vice
president of sustainability at the
Plastics industry Association um I'm
here to do to talk to you today a little
bit about plastic recycling Technologies
how we currently do it how we can do it
better and and have a discussion about
potential policies that can support
recycling in New Hampshire New Hampshire
does a really great job um but like in
all things we can do them better and so
let's talk about that and see how we can
work together to improve
recycling um the Plastics industry
Association is the trade Association
that was started in
1937 and it represents the full plastic
Supply chain that includes the equipment
and mold makers the material suppliers
and the processors converters who make
those Pro who who use that equipment and
those materials to make the products
that we use all throughout our daily
lives um we also want to note that all
our members include the recyclers who
take those products when you're done
with them and they make them into new
things as well so when we talk about the
Plastics industry in the United States
that is a a very large group um so that
is the seventh largest manufacturing
industry in the United States um
representing over a million jobs and
over 548 billion dollars in shipments
each year um in addition to that
obviously we are very Reliant or many of
the industries that we have in the
United States are very reliant on
Plastics to be able to do the things
that they need to do to provide Comfort
safety access and convenience for all of
you and all of your citizens in New
Hampshire in particular um we employ
almost 5,000 people in the Plastics
industry and then when we talk about
those dependent Industries which include
medical construction uh packaging Etc
that would be almost 200,000 employees
so representing about three M or 300 uh
million in payrolls and 30 million in
taxes so I work with the sustainability
team in the organization and we work
with our members as you imagine for the
Plastics industry sustainability is a
very core priority for us we love to say
that we love plastic and we hate plastic
waste we want to make sure that we are
addressing uh the issues and challenges
that surround the sustainability of
plastics and work to improve them we do
those in three different kind of
priority areas we promote plastic
circularity we want to eliminate plastic
waste in the environment and we want to
make sure that we're using resources
responsibly the ones that we use to make
Plastics but also those Plastics
themselves so in talking today I'm also
going to talk pretty quickly because I
want to make sure that there's
definitely a lot of time for questions
um I think it's a it's a pretty
simplistic question to ask but what is
recycling if you ask a lot of people
they think it's an action they think
that it's an act that they are doing
putting the pet bottle in the blue bin I
guess at which point magic converts it
into something new it's not an action
it's a process um it's actually a bunch
of different steps all of which that
need to happen correctly for something
to be actually recycle right and that is
true for Plastics as well as many other
materials a lot of the things that we
talk today are not unique to Plastics
right so when we talk about the
challenges that exist for us the great
thing about that is the opportunities to
improve Plastics recycling will also
improve for other materials Metals glass
fiber Etc
ladies so when we talk about that
process of recycling I like to talk
about it in four different buckets so
that's collection sortation processing
and conversion but the other thing that
I want to make sure that we talk about
very clearly at the beginning um is that
recycling is different everywhere you
are so like we often say like I mean I'm
sure that you as politicians can
appreciate this you know much like
politics recycling is local it depends
on where you're at in your community
even where you may live within that
community so we want to make sure that
that's important because acceptance
rates what materials are accepted
different differ widely uh across the
United States in 2021 the sustainable
packaging Coalition published an access
study um and it showed various
acceptance rates for materials across
the United States so for example uh
aluminum cans in non-deposit states were
accepted in 89% of locations whereas pet
water bottles beverage bottles were
accepted in 87% right really high but
that's not everything um so if you talk
about polystyrene not expanded
polystyrene but polystyrene itself
extruded um that's 37% and that actually
matches the acceptance rate for other
things like aluminum foil which people
are often surprised is not just accepted
everywhere um we travel a lot and and I
often give presentations on how to
recycle and one of the things that I
often tell people that's very surprising
is paper napkins paper napkins are not
widely recyclable everywhere but then
you could also say um who here things
that are uh pizza box is recyclable
right so in 90 over 90% of paper mills
in the United States will accept a pizza
box so pizza boxes are actually very
widely recyclable in this in the United
States as well well now the Mills are
different than the communities some
communities choose not to because
they're worried about food waste and
rodents and things like that but they
are able to be recycled and they are
very widely recycled so that's why you
know many of the misconceptions about
recycling are are shared amongst the
materials so when we talk about
collection I think in popular culture we
often think of it as that blue bin that
I mentioned where we are Trucking that
out to our curb where then someone picks
it up and it it again goes away
magically right um that's true many
places um in fact about 50% of
communities in the United States and
people or citizens in the United States
households have access to curbside
recycling that's not necessarily true
for New Hampshire in New Hampshire n
71% of of your households actually
recycle via drop off Community drop off
which is actually that second image
there um that's actually taken from the
Newark post um recycling center that
opened in
2021 but also there are other forms of
recycling besides curbside and uh and
Community drop off there are things like
store drop off so often a very common
weighted collectings like film um but
also batteries printer cartridges Etc
they're also male-in recycling options
as well um for certain types of products
where it's really important to recycle
them but you know there's not
necessarily a lot of of concentration of
that material in one geographic location
so there are different ways to collect
it but we have to collect it first we as
an industry have invested billions of
dollars in recycling technology and we
as as parts of our coalitions like the
recycling partnership and others have ex
have invested even more or or additional
money um in in improving things like
collection but if someone can't get it
in the bin or they don't put it in the
bin in the first place like all of that
is for
not so when we think about collection we
can improve that in three different ways
we can discuss
access um we can discuss engagement and
then we can also talk about education
those are three important things around
how we can improve collection so in
Access let's talk about the national
recycling access so these dumbers come
from the recycling partnership's most
recent report published in January of
this year 73% of communities have access
to some form of recycling whether that's
curbside or in those Community drop offs
um 27% don't in New Hampshire which is
those which are those numbers in the
center um 95% of single family
households have access unfortunately
multif family is six now I will put a
big caveat here so the recycling
partnership in particular is really
focused on Equitable access which is
really important they want to make sure
that it's as easy for you to throw it
away as it is to recycle it and vice
versa so when they're talking about this
number there that is Equitable access
that does not necessarily work super
well in New Hampshire where you have
such a very high Community drop off for
recycling but it does mean that it is
easier for people to throw things away
than it is to
recycle when we talk about engagement
right that's the next just because you
have it doesn't mean you do it so
nationally 59% of people who have access
to recycling actually do it it's a
little bit less in New Hampshire at
about
50% um and what does that mean
specifically for you as a state it means
that you are losing
172,000 pounds of material to landfill
or uh you know incineration that could
otherwise be
recycled um we want want to make sure
that that engagement number is up and
how do we do that that's actually
through education right so when I
mentioned that that recycling is
different everywhere it's incredibly
complex and we recognize that but
ensuring that people understand and are
confident in how they can recycle where
they're located is really important so
this is an example of portsmouth's work
with waste management or WM now excuse
me to talk about the kinds of items that
they do accept and don't accept those
vary again why do that why does That
Vary we can talk about that during the
discussion um but it's just true that
not every location accepts every single
type of material in the same
way um also what that really helps with
is trust and building trust in recycling
um we actually see decreased rates of
the trust in recycling overall in the
United States which is really
unfortunate if you don't believe that
recycling is actually happening then you
are less likely to actually do that and
it un fortunately becomes a little bit
of a spiral right that if you don't do
it then then your recycling rates are
low and then people say recycling is a
myth and so more people become
discouraged so we want to make sure that
we are showing that recycling is
happening and that it is important and
giving people the information that they
need to feel empowered that's like why
Plastics industry Association has worked
on a new initiative called recycling is
real where we've created a series of
videos and we're engaging with people to
actually show companies Recycling and
converting plas Plastics and other
materials into new
products when we move on to sortation so
for single stream the curbside material
much of that needs to be sorted because
it includes multiple materials in the
same location this is a photo of a
material recovery facility from where
that happens so this is at the very
beginning of that process where many
where many conveyors and and a very
manual process of people sitting there
and picking out potential contaminants
um I whenever I go to murfs I always ask
them uh what's your favorite contaminant
you've seen um the sheer number of
bowling balls that get recycled um is
staggering um that by the way is called
wish cycling where people put something
into the bin because they really hope
but they're not sure that it is actually
recyclable if you don't know that
something is recyclable please do not
put it in the bin um because that
increases contamination and
contamination is a really big issue
because this process is very very
expensive relative to everything else
making sure that we are separating these
things in a very uh efficient way um and
as such if loads of material are too
contaminated they are rejected by
material recovery facilities and they
are then sent directly to landfill so
all that other great material and all of
your uh you know fellow neighbors um and
the great work that they did gets
diverted along with that um there are no
murfs in New Hampshire unfortunately
there are 400 in the United States um
but there are some pretty close ones
around here um there's I think five
pretty close in Massachusetts there's
one in uh Maine and there's one in uh uh
new Vermont as well and I can provide
that information afterwards if if people
are interested in seeing where those are
um if you've never been to a murf I
really encourage you to go they're
fascinating um they have a a lot of
really cool technology that they work
with such as size filters magnets and
Eddy currents to separate um Metals out
they can classify by shooting um jets of
air to separate different types of paper
or different types of plastics they also
use Optical sorters that's the image on
the right um and then robotics which is
that image there in the in the center
many murfs now are really investing in
both Optical sortation and uh robotics
these are two types of equipment that
really enable them to uh very quickly
adapt to the incoming waste streams that
evolve over time you know what we
recycle now is very different than we
recycled in the 90s for example we're
not reading as much on newspapers
unfortunately so there's just less
newspaper that's going into these murfs
and so uh but there is however more
flexibles and or more uh other types of
plastics and so having options and
technologies that can sort those out is
really key and it's it's also very
expensive an optical sorder can can be
up to $2 million right so it it is
something that is is very expensive for
them to do and takes a
while once we talk once we have all that
material collected and bailed it is then
sent to other locations those are
processors like Plastics recyclers like
um uh let's see film or or Fiber pulpers
things like that smelters um and in our
industry when we're talking about how we
recycle that there are a few common
steps but again depending on the type of
material that you as a company are
accepting into your into your um
facility those are very those can vary
very widely um and the the that include
size reduction which is a really nice
way to say shredding right making it
smaller so it's easier to handle we can
then screen out spe specific items like
in contaminants like metals and glass
that inevitably find find their way into
our recycling uh facilities we can wash
off all of the food contamination that
not everybody has done a great job of
rinsing off whether that's hot or cold
we can then also float and sink so one
of the things that we often like to
encourage people to do if you have a pet
bottle is to put that cap back on right
so we need to remember to keep that cap
on that way that that very small cap
Which is less than 2 in by the way and a
fun fact for everybody here if an item
is less than 2 in by 2 in in in two
different uh you know uh different
directions um it will not be recycled
right so straws not readily recyclable
through through um automatic processes
but neither are um business cards
neither are many small pieces of paper
or aluminum foil wrappers right so very
small items don't make it through those
murfs and so when we float in sink
separation enables us to be able to
separate out that pet and that and that
polypropylene cap that is used on top of
those products and then once we have
those separated and cleaned and washed
we extrude them and then make pellets
out of them so that we can then send
them along the process um that's those
are called mechanical and mechanical is
the very classic way that we think about
recycling in the United States and
elsewhere there are also a growing
amount of of other recycling
Technologies um in the pl Plastics
industry um some people call them
Advanced I think that there are some
pretty amazing mechanical recycling
Innovations so um generally they don't
like it when we call these Advanced and
I totally get that so it's generally
Advanced molecular or chemical and these
are technologies that enable us to
recycle materials that are too degraded
so if you recycle um a pet bottle a
certain number of times over time it
gets a little grayer and a little bit
yellower that's for a lot of reasons
food contamination the heat process
itself um and so after too long we need
to recycle that and remake new polymers
by the way that number is six and I
think I find really interesting when I
say our issues are the same as other
issues um you can only really typically
recycle fiber six times as well before
it needs to be discarded but the
difference between fiber products like
paper and Plastics is that we can take
those materials and we can make them
into new products again through
Technologies like purification de
lization or a form of conversion like
gasification or paralysis that makes a
very basic feed stock that's much like
oil or natural gas that we then use to
make Plastics all over again this also
really helps for certain types of
applications like medical or food
contact where we want to make sure that
those contamination rates are very very
low and then finally when we talk about
conversion right so in the United States
we recycle about 6 billion pounds of
recycled plastic Plastics each year
that's a really great number but it's
candidly not enough that reflects to um
somewhere between 8 and 10% of recycling
a year it's not a great number but it's
also very misleading compared to other
types of products or materials because
that number in our denominator includes
the amount of plastic that is used in
cars and in other durable applications
whereas in other materials um those can
be
uh those are less common and so their
recycling rates are often reflected to
be very high and we'll talk a little bit
about when we talk about specific
product types how those can work in a
different way um the conversion process
is complicated and using recycled
content especially mechanically recycled
content is not necessarily easy um it as
material tends to be more expensive um
there is a premium relative to virgin
because obviously there were a lot more
costs associated with the processing of
that material um and also that process
especially mechanically could impact the
mechanical or aesthetic appearances of
those products um like viscosity so
imagine anticipating having to work with
something that kind of flowed like maple
syrup and then instead having to deal
with something that flowed like honey
right so those are very different and as
we try to use use our molds to make new
Plastics we have to think about those in
different ways um so when often I talk
about this and that's collection
sortation and processing um people are
always like so the product tends to have
you know aesthetic differences which are
really important to communicate to
Consumers so that they don't look at a
gray bottle and think something's wrong
with that package and they don't want to
buy it um it's more expensive um and
people love to say that they will that
they want to they want to buy more
recycled content if you ask them over
70% of people will say that they're
willing to pay more for recycled content
but I think that if you ask those people
if they went to church if they voted
somewhere outside of New Hampshire where
you'll have a much higher engagement
rate um or floss like they're also going
to say that they they do that really
high it there it's really easy to say it
um it's not necessarily as easy to show
it and actually do it in real
life so it's a challenge for us but how
are we doing so if we talk about
recycling rates as I mentioned earlier
about that National recycling rate we
actually say in the United States that
we recycle our our total recycling rate
is about 32% of material not great we
definitely want to do better and we're
working on ways to do better on that um
but I want to go back one more slide so
before we jump to that but we also want
to look at like State Recycling rates so
your overall recycling rate in New
Hampshire and this is is a source of the
from ball the company that makes glass
jars um this is their 50 states of
recycling 2.0 um that they just
published your overall recycling rate is
23% with aluminum at 29 but pet
recycling right so those materials that
we're using in packaging also
29% if we look and this is also from the
recycling partnership state of recycling
report um those numbers compared to
nationally versus New Hampshire they
vary widely but you know we do see that
that especially for very common types of
plastics packaging we do recycle them in
ways that are somewhat comparable to
those other types so we want to make
sure that we are all working together to
increase recycling
overall um but if it's so expensive and
it's uh and it's difficult to work with
why do we do it candidly there are a lot
of benefits to recycling and I think
that you know we can talk a little bit
more about that um during the discussion
if you're interested I just want to
summarize a few here quickly right so
here is the current benefit of recycling
to the New Hampshire economy through
metals and other forms Electronics
electronic recycling is actually very
common here in New Hampshire um and what
I'll also point out is as we grow
recycling that is really great for jobs
so for every 10,000 pounds of material
that goes to landfill that that relates
to about one job for every 10,000 pounds
of material that's recycled that's 90
jobs so more recycling is more jobs also
we know that a little bit less than half
of the material that goes to New
Hampshire landfills comes from out of
state rather than being paid for at once
recycling enables you to be paid for it
twice both when it's collected and and
then when you sell it again um it
promotes resiliency right so we
understood during covid that we actually
had a very fragile supply chain globally
and so having recycled content in
internally enables us to be able to help
kind of smooth out some of those bumps
it's also just candidly resource
conservation right so many of the things
that we use are finite and so we want to
make sure that we are using them for as
long as possible at the highest use
possible um but that's also also means
less energy and less water use so
recycled content versus material so it
takes 75% less energy to generally
manufact to recycle a product than it
does to manufacture it from a raw
material so making sure that that's
really important and then landfill
diversion New Hampshire has a goal to
reduce a certain amount of your landfill
over time um and so by being able to
recycle that it's really
important and then talking very leastly
again I'll I'll discuss a lot of this
during discussion if you have questions
but thinking about policies that can
really help support recycling here in
New Hampshire thinking about things like
increasing access right recognizing that
that multif Family Access is so low how
do we increase that how do we enable
that everybody can recycle as easily as
they can
landfill um increasing and developing
instate sortation and processing how can
you actually collect and sort that
material inside the state of New
Hampshire rather than exporting it
because sorted material is more valuable
even if it's being processed elsewhere
um or and then even again going a step
further and process seen it here as well
um New Hampshire has has already done
one one thing to help with that in the
advanced recycling space is a
recognizing that advanced advanced
recycling is manufacturing and so is
permanent as such um we can also support
demand and that can be by establishing
minimum recycled content standards that
I think are real and attainable uh for
for type types of products that's a
really great way to actually pull
product through that entire process
because if there's a demand at the end
if people really want this or need this
we will find ways we will innovate it is
it is a it is a signal to invest and
then also using the power of the purse
right preferential State purchasing you
do recognize that that um recycled
content is ideal and so finding ways to
further encourage that is really great
one caveat here I will say is I think
that there is a a goal of trying to make
sure that you use the product that has
the most recycled content you want to
make sure that you are thoughtful um
comparing apples and oranges so 100%
paper product and a 30% uh pet bottle
for example they will have different um
Greenhouse Gas Energy costs and things
so recognizing that from a life cycle
analysis perspective you still want to
make sure or it's it's ideal to make
sure that you were you were choosing the
one with the lowest environmental
footprint and then extended producer
responsibility and return to deposit
schemes these are a really great way to
pay for this like I said this equipment
is very expensive trying to find ways to
incentivize and and educate people on
how to actually collect and and recycle
the material is really really um
important I think over time the industry
has evolved and we are very supportive
of good epr what is good epr right so
it's realistic um it includes uh it's
not punitive it includes all materials
that go into the bin and other things to
consider which we can talk about during
discussion and then return deposit
schemes many people know those as as
bottle bills um so that's actually a
really really effective way to collect
um those states that have bottle bills
actually have a significantly higher
recycling rate um for those products
compared to those who don't um and they
are not necessarily just for bottles
they they're used WID ly throughout
other materials as well but they are a
really great uh policy tool um so with
that um I want to save time for
questions and so I want to thank
everybody for for your your patience as
slides thank you Mr creger that was um
very
interesting um my my question
is what I find
as a consumer recycler person who
recycles whatever
um with our transfer stations in New
Hampshire as you know we bring our trash
to a collection point and they have you
know recycling bins that you can put
things in there are certain things that
they won't take that are you know the
the number threes or fours or fives or
sixes of you know that the little number
that's in in the little
triangle and if they may take some they
may take them but they can't be blue or
black colored and so people find that
very frustrating that because they want
to recycle these
materials but we have issues with
municipalities rejecting them because
maybe they can't find a market to sell
them to or get them
to how how do we how do we work with
that I think first of all I recognize
that that is very uh frustrating I also
recycle at home and I'm like okay what
can I recycle here what can't I um so I
think there's two different things that
we can do to address those issues one we
as an industry are working on things
like designing for recycling ensuring
that the products that we make more
closely conform to the recycling system
that we have in the United States you
mentioned colored versus CLE clear
colored products often tend to be very
difficult to recycle because they T the
end result and so when a company then
wants to buy that material on the other
side they want to use it in a colored
application so it becomes very
challenging so thinking about ways to
encourage clear um and not necessarily
just clear but things like that um
making sure that we are designing parts
so that they can be easily removed so
that we don't contaminate different
types of streams which is often a a
similar problem why some items get
rejected um but then we also on the back
end are working on new technologies that
will enable us to collect those
materials so or or recycle those
materials a really great example is a
collaborative that's happening in
Houston Texas so uh that is work that's
being done by cylix Exxon lion delbel
and a few other organizations I
apologize for skipping their names but
they have Community drop off hubs in
Kingwood Texas and other locations and
they enable you to just put all of your
Plastics into a bag which makes it
actually really easy to recycle it you
can put it all in the same bag and then
put it in there and then cyclics will
then separate all of that material and
those those colored products and those
products that wouldn't necessarily be
able to have an individual Market can
then be recycled through advanced
recycling Technologies thank you
representative Murray thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
so as a parent of three children I can
tell you that my mind goes to places uh
that it it just nearly explodes some
days when we're looking at toys or
sporting equipment or any of those types
of things and we work really hard to try
and find um those mailin or rebate
places or drop off uh in store centers
um and they're feeling far between to be
honest um so I guess my question to you
would be where does epr fit in this
whole conversation around
specifically kid oriented and family
oriented things that we use in our daily
lives yeah I love that question because
I think that uh parents do have a lot of
challenges because of the types of
products that they have and you know and
they get so many from every single
birthday and and they they sometimes
just show up from school but also the
types of packaging that is you know
single serf packaging for for kids um
it's a challenge first of all I commend
you for looking for reuse use options so
when we talk about that waste hierarchy
we do want to make sure that we are
thinking about recycling as the last
option right so we do want to reduce if
you don't need these products don't buy
these products find ways to reuse them
or you know be able to donate them and
find ways to to uh extend their lives
that way um epr can be very helpful in
those for what we often call like large
bulky items um because they can help in
incentivize the collection of those
materials um in some way either through
the deposits I will say that the that
you need to construct epr in such a way
that is thinking about those kinds of
objects most epr in the United States
and other places are really focused on
packaging right and so and most of the
materials that we are recycling in in
our communities and murfs Etc are are
packaging items so those items can be
addressed by epr some ways but thinking
about policies specifically that could
encourage that such as Grant programs
the EPA has been working on those right
now um to increase re uh Recycling and
new Innovative uh collection
methods representative
bman thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question um this is all
very new to me so uh one thing that we
heard in previous testimony and I'm
sorry if I missed this is um the
percentage of a plastic product that is
able to be
recycled and then in terms of of
creating new plastic items that only a
small percentage of that new product can
include recycled products so I I don't
remember the percentage right but I I
think it was something like even if you
create a bottle with recycled plastic
that at least 30% of it had to be virgin
plastic
so it it seems like it might help a
little but my question is do you do you
have any information on that like what
is the percentage that that that can be
used in a new product I guess thank you
for letting me talk through that sure um
and and yes it it varies per product and
and the reason being is because of that
mechanically recycled aspect where there
are again aesthetic issues or also
mechanical issues where as we recycle
these products that it may again in um
address they may become more brittle
over time things like that so in some
applications we do need to incorporate
new um virgin material to help kind of
support that or use other forms of
additives um that is not uh that there's
not like a single number like no product
can only have 30% in fact a pet bottle
can have 100% um postc consumer
mechanically recycled content in it for
example the pet bottle itself um certain
large blown film applications like for
certain jug types that are made out of H
um highdensity
polyethylene um are uh they they may
need up to 20% virgin right so that just
be that is enable to select it so the
the challenge is by material it differs
and then the added complication is with
Advanced recycling we can then enable
100% recy recycled content as well so
there's no great number right there that
really currently exists um I'm sorry to
say but it it would vary by product um
and we want to make sure how we can
increase it more and more followup um
sure thank you um you you know you noted
oh there are these specific ones um do
you have any sense of again I'm looking
if you don't have the number but is that
more than it's not is it a small number
that can that is like
100% um recycled materials is that 1%
can you give me some idea of like what
we're talking about here in terms of
What's um you
know what is able to be recy I hear you
yeah thank you I hear you and and and
yeah we're we're we're veering into
speculation so recognize this is this is
a this is a a scientific wild guess um
but that number is actually very high
right so more and more we are increasing
our ability to use more and more
mechanically recycled content um so for
rigid products things that have uh you
know large wall thicknesses things like
that we can have much much higher
content somewhere closer to 75 even up
to 100% for things that are very very
thin or very very flexible like films
making sure that we have the ability
that they still be able to not have
holes which is kind of counterproductive
to a film bag and for example um you
know those numbers vary and postc
consumer recycle content can be
somewhere like 15 to 20% po industrial
content which is has which is much
cleaner um which has fewer contamination
um and has it gone through um fewer heat
Cycles you can you can increase that
even further maybe to uh 30
40% U representive Bixby and then
representive poen
yeah so one
challenge seems to with mechanical
recycling is excuse
me is the um potential
contamination and and this can come from
both what was in the in the container
that was recycled and also what is in
the plastic that is being uh recycled to
get there so be all Plastics have you
know various plasticizers and other
things that change the color and the um
you know radiation or UV resistance etc
etc um
and so and those things can make it
unacceptable for food contact so um it
seems like the uh chemical recycling or
Advanced recycling might be a better
option for food contact first of all is
there so the question is in two part a
couple parts one
is is there a possibility of using
mechanically recycled material for for
food
contact and how uh how can we increase
the amount of chemical chemically
recycled uh material for uh that would
be available for food contact because
that would you know definitely you have
more control over the pro final product
there uh and uh are we at a point of
being at a at a scale where that's going
to be useful for a broad swath of the uh
food
containers sure and I may miss aspects
of that so please feel free to you know
keep me honest and if I if I miss those
but yes so um mechanically recycled
content can be used in food food contact
applications it's actually widely used
right now we do love to see more
recycled content in general which also
means in those food contact applications
right I I just gave an example of a pet
soft drink bottle that can be you know
mechanically recycled at 100% so we have
the ability to do that it does require a
very specific um observation of how that
material is collected and processed and
we work with the FDA to make sure that
those products at the end of the day um
do not do not have the contamin or the
contaminants that are in them are below
appropriate levels um so that they can
be used in food contact so so yes we do
that yes we are working more and more um
to enable us to recycle more of those
products through mechanically recycled
which and I would like to say like we
really support mechanically recycled
products like so compared to Advanced
recycling um it it does have a lower
energy input and it does and it is lower
cost and so if a product can can be
mechanically recycled it should be
mechanically recycled uh so so um we
would love to see more of that so I
think one of the other parts of that is
um how can we increase that so there's a
few different ways so we are increasing
um investment in those kinds of cleaning
technologies that enable us to remove
odors to um promote um the cleaning
filtering of the of the products
themselves um things like that so we are
working in those spaces um and we are
increasing that amount of content I will
say that the amount of mechanically
recycled content content that is
approved for food contact does not meet
the the projected demand so if you look
at what brands have made for their
commitments um we cannot currently meet
that with that with that mechanically
recycled content so we will need to um
increase that supply and then also um
help cover the the differ difference
with um Advanced recycled content
representative
Penza and then representative
Murray I just had a question concerning
New Hampshire specifically and if um if
you knew where our recycling is is going
and being processed and then I have a
other question um I don't have that
information I apologize but there are
several Lo local ones and and it makes
much more sense from an economic
perspective for those to to go very
local so New Hampshire Massachusetts or
uh Maine not New Hampshire excuse me
Vermont followup so um I lived in in um
on the Sea Coast in New Hampshire and so
we had a transfer station uh in Rye and
I got to know uh those guys really well
I've I worked for a um water company so
I followed like Plastics with water
bottles and all that for a long time and
huge thing about recycling um and it was
um and they explained to me and most
people just really didn't know so I just
kind of wanted to um about New Hampshire
just in specific so people would come
there and they would they'd have you
know certain buckets for certain things
of course you couldn't you know you
couldn't recycle any caps on bottles and
all of that you have to put your caps
separate um because they're all colored
caps all that kind of stuff so but glass
for example you know everybody was you
know rinsed out all their stuff and
threw their glass there but they weren't
taking that it was in a big bin and all
that glass was just going into a
landfill that everybody thought that was
being recycled um and there's also these
single streams that are going on all
across New Hampshire where they think
that their stuff is sorted and recycled
and it's not it's going straight to
landfill so I just didn't know if you
could speak to any of that um these
gentlemen at that transfer station told
me you know the absolute truth and um
and so people were going there and you
know doing their d diligence but it
wasn't yeah and they told me there's
nothing really happening here in New
Hampshire most of that stuff once China
stopped taking our recycling we were in
a a real pickle so I'd love you to speak
to some of that if you have any
information sure happy to do that so I'm
going to jump around apologies on that
so the the the China point so um most
recycling on the East Coast did not go
to China so most of that would happen in
the United States so um that reference
by the way is in 2017 China decided that
they would no longer accept mixed
materials so Plastics and paper that was
primarily on the west coast uh so in
addition in the United States uh we
recycle more than 90% of the material
that is collected here um and we import
a very small percentage of that to other
locations those locations are primarily
Mexico and Canada um so glass and glass
recycling um you know I I don't work for
the glass industry but I I would say in
their defense that that um they would
also love their material to be recycled
as well um often when that is collected
separately and a lot of materials are
sometimes collected separately for a
myriad of reasons some of which is their
their Community requires it some of it
is that those markets may may be
commercially viable um sometimes and
sometimes they're not and so they they
separate them and they continue to
separate them for the opportunities when
they can sell those um you know uh for
profit and then sometimes that they do
that because uh it enables them to not
have that contamination in another
stream uh like I mentioned so sometimes
people really want to recycle certain
items they have it in their head and so
uh if you don't Source separate it there
they'll just put it somewhere else but
there are a myriad of reasons why a murf
might collect something but not actually
recycle it and you know it it is very
very context
specific representative Murray thank you
uh for yes thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question so one
of the questions that I did have was
around multi-layer packaging and so
things like potato chip bags squeezy
food pouches dog food cat food you name
it treat bags um is that better suited
for something like the advanced chemical
type of recycling versus the mechanical
and could you speak to generally that
stuff often ends up in a landfill um so
can you speak to the direction that
that's going sure so multi- laminates
first of all what are multi-laminate
films so they have multiple different
layers of they're they're often not one
specific type of polymer um and all of
those different layers have a different
function they may be um something to
print on that you can have high impact
printing on
they may be a layer that is actually a
vapor barrier or a barrier that is tear
resistant or or you know that so that it
the their structural Integrity to the to
the package itself um it may be a UV
blocker things like that which your
those the reason that they tend to have
multiple layers is because each one of
those layers is doing a different role
um now as an industry we are looking at
Innovations to simplify those and to
have more what are called monom material
flexibles um and we're doing a lot of
really really cool things on on that
where it's you know um where we Orient
the polymers One Direction and then we
take another layer and we Orient the
polymers another Direction it's it's
very cool and very technical um so we
are looking to innovate more towards
that idea of design for recycling to
make it easier to potentially
mechanically recycle these in the future
but for those multi laminates that we
currently have yes Advanced recycling is
a really uh
uh is a is a very uh helpful option to
be able to recycle those and I'd also
point out the reason that we use those
multi laminates is because they are so
much more convenient for people like
it's like well why why do we use those
because you know we we really like to
have those products and they actually
have much lower um like carbon
Footprints and other items and costs
associated to it versus other
materials thank you uh representative
moris thank you m thank you for taking
my question um you mentioned earlier and
maybe I missed something along the way
but um all of the New England states it
sounds like have the Sorting centers or
murfs as you called them is there do you
know why we do not have one in New
Hampshire I don't know why you don't
have one in New Hampshire I'd love you
to have one in New Hampshire followup
followup um is there legislation that
goes along with getting something like
that going or is it more of like like a
personal business type of situation so
there are there are obviously business
decisions and those those murfs um are
most often in the United States are
privately run right so a really great
example I I mentioned earlier is WM WM
not doesn't just do uh landfills they
also do a lot of uh sortation so they
are they they make economic decisions on
the ability to aggregate enough material
that it becomes economically viable to
invest but there are other items such as
permitting or tax incentives things like
that that can attract specific
businesses um representative Howard and
then representative
Bixby thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um I have
actually have two questions that are
sort of not related to each other the
first one is in my town um the head of
the DPW that it keeps changing things
around be to CH to save money or to not
spend as much money and um I I was
wondering do we pay do we pay these
these centers to take our our trash or
do they pay or do they buy it from us
our our recyclables and my second
question um is in the news recently
there was a um a um news of th millions
of part plastic particulates and water
bottles and I'm just wondering if that's
safe for people or if if you guys are
working to um mitigate
that sure so taking those in order so
typically a a community will contract
with a station and I I don't and I will
confess that that I I don't necessarily
know like the relationships um for
everybody in in New Hampshire what I
will say is that the idea of epr is
really helpful because it can help
support the costs of those so that you
don't have somebody constantly trying to
change things around to make something
more economically viable on the topic of
microplastics or nanoplastics in in in
bottles so that is that is currently an
area of study um we you know I work in
sustainability um and so this is rapidly
outside my knowledge Zone um what I will
say is that um I think that the United
Nations did a study in 2019 of
microplastics and they found that yes
while we do ingest
microplastics um at very very small
amounts um they we also pass a large
percentage of those out straight through
and that there's no really great data
right now that understands that health
impact so um we as an industry are
investing in more research we encourage
more research in this area not just of
the detection um for the for high impact
uh like articles for to discover these
items um but the next step for that is
is is there actual a health impact as
well so we are working on that to
explore those impacts one last question
representative
yeah so um I was so um in the most
recent issue of the American scientist
there was a piece about uh a group at
Colorado State University that is
working on something called multi-block
uh polymers that would have uh the the
the polymer bonds would be easier to be
to be broken down in a recycling process
and I'm wondering if this is something
that is uh anywhere near being being uh
available for uh for being used broadly
and how that sort of thing might be
separated from other sorts of
plastics I I will confess that I'm not
familiar with that article in multiblock
polymers so so in general what I would
say is that and and I'm guessing based
on on that description is that these are
are blocks within the polymer chain that
enable them to break down easier so that
would um that could conceivably be more
like it could make forms of advanced
recycling more efficient it's not
necessarily valuable to Mechanical
recycling where we're not breaking those
polymer chains down right so I'm I'm I'm
I'm speculating here I would be happy to
take a look at it and follow up with you
okay thanks thank you and thank you so
much again for uh coming to New
Hampshire to come and speak with us and
and give us this presentation and take
our questions um we really appreciate
the time that you've taken and um thank
you thank you for having me I really
appreciate it all right all right um we
are adjourned until one o'clock so go
have some lunch and we'll see you back
sessions
e
I'd like our members to please take
their
seats environment and agriculture
seats your second
two all right we'll get ourselves
and good afternoon I'd like to W welcome
everybody back to um environment
agriculture this afternoon we we have a
series of bills that we're going to talk
about in full committee work session I'm
going to open up this committee work
session um we will start by our
discussion with Excuse me HB
1182 which uh seeks to add certain equin
practices to the definition of animal
cruelty and um I'd like to open it up
for
discussion with our committee members to
see
uh what our thoughts are uh regarding
this legislation um anybody have any
thoughts representative
Kwa thank you madam chair um so my
thought is is in the
discussion cruelty is already defined as
all of the items that were listed and I
think that by narrowing although we
would think that this would be
broadening
um that when we start listing things we
will forget things and I believe that
our animal cruelty laws that we worked
on uh quite extensively to get to where
it is today covers the issues at hand in
this
legislation any other comments from the
committee representative
Duty go ahead and then represent and
then representative smart don't don't
duke it out over there you know um
yeah I honestly think that this is a
fairly modest Bill and um IT addresses
some things that um you know are quite
egregious that some
people some people may not consider that
they are um cruel uh they more in the
area of uh competitive
advantages um so I don't see any harm in
modifying the cruelty to add um I
believe it's these four um issues thank
you representative smart hi
um I agree that these are
heinous these practices um but I think
list if we start listing things that are
cruel to animals or or anything we run a
risk of leaving something out if we're
um definition of Cruelty covers
everything in one F swoop um and I think
in this instance the problem is um that
when people see this they're not coming
forward with it and maybe education
might be the way to go rather than
passing a bill um because there are
already things in place um to bring in
animals from out of state for shows
horses they need to have a um a health
certificate from a federally licensed
veterinarian um I would think that that
would be picked up then because this is
not stuff that's the health certificate
has to be within 30 days
um are you talking about HB 1182 is that
the animal practices right animal
cruelty that's that's with the umin
yeah and so and and in the state of New
Hampshire these are not practiced um
it's the and for showing purposes to
sell your animal bring your animal out
of state to show your animal to sell it
I don't think the Deerfield fair is the
place that they're going to be doing
that we don't have large um hores shows
here um like in some of the other states
like New York where it they have spe
it's equin country you have these big
farms so I just I think that this is a
nonstarter there's no way to enforce
it
so that's got representative Murray
thank you madam chair for taking my
question or just comment comment yeah
we're just just very Loosely talking
about this and what what our thoughts
are as a committee sure and I think to
the members Point uh representative
smart was talking about COG and cogin
are used either through like Interstate
transport for horse shows or in the sale
of an animal and I think that's what she
might be
referencing they also have to have a
health certificate so they don't have
any communicable diseases besides the
cogin test right representative Bixby
you had a comment yeah yeah
um I was
um kind of on the fence about this until
it was the issue was mentioned that
um excuse me
um sometimes prosecutors are hesitant to
uh work under the existing animal
cruelty law because they don't think
they're necessarily going to win the
case because it's not specific enough
and I think that this
will this would provide the specificity
that a prosecutor might need in order to
actually bring and win the
case representative H Haskins thank you
madam
chair I'm horrified that this kind of
thing is still going
on and if the animal cruelty laws were
all it took it wouldn't be happening and
I
think to have some specificity is better
than not having any it doesn't mean that
it will cover all conditions but it will
cover the
and I'm in favor of
it thank
you representative Howard thank you
madam chair um I'm just wondering if the
members think that this would be a
punitive I
do you know quite frankly I don't I
don't think that this would be a
preventative at all I mean I to me
animal cruelty is is pretty much well
defined
um in in 6 RSA 644 colon
um
H oh well no here it says in the section
cruelty shall include but not be limited
to Acts or emissions injurious or
detrimental to the health safety or
welfare of any animal including the
abandoning of any animal without proper
provision for its care sustenance and
protection section or shelter and I
think that's really broad enough to
include hoof soaring gingering tail
nicking tail blocking which are all
detrimental to the health and safety and
Welfare of the animal so to then um
clutter up this statute with specific
kinds of injuries opens the door to have
you know a whole list of stuff that is
already covered under the first line of
this statute so for me I mean
especially um USCF the eoin
Federation um they have policies um they
have pre-m competition checks um the
community already is self- policing and
the fact is the people are what we heard
in testimony is that people are not
reporting it well that's not the
statute's fault that people are not
repor supporting it and I I'm I don't
agree I'm sorry representative Bixby I
think that um a prosecutor could
certainly uh say that these these
practices fall under um 644 colon 8
section one
absolutely but representative coma thank
you madam chair and just to uh piggy
back on what you said what we heard in
testimony was that people would not come
forth and let others know that this was
happening so that the animal cruelty
laws could not be enforced by adding
this this isn't going to make them come
forth any more than they already do now
I think the key is is to educate the
people that when they see this that they
need to call law enforcement or the
State
Vet because that's the only way we're
going to correct the issue and that's
what's not happening as we heard in
testimony because people won't come
forward so the purpose of this
um U commissioner Jasper you have your
hand
up oh thank you for that
clarification this would be uh an issue
for law enforcement then especially it's
in the criminal code um so the purpose
of a work session I guess is for us to
try and figure out whether we want to um
put any amendments on legislation or not
and I I don't know that we
do um unless anybody has any ideas
representative Bixby yeah um I'm my
feeling is that um this doesn't need
amending I think that uh I I still think
that it uh does make sense but um
obviously I have some I'm not there's a
little bit of disagreement about that
but I don't think that there's any way
to improve it by amending it okay
representative
Duty uh yeah my question would be um if
we left it as it is and put this in into
law uh wouldn't that put the hores shows
on notice that if they come to New
Hampshire and these practices uh and
they turn an Blind Eye to these
practices that they will in fact be
prosecuted I mean and if we don't have
that many horse shows in the state I
mean you know couldn't we have um a
somebody from the Department of
Agriculture go to the shows and just
ensure that none of these practices are
happening if other people will not go
ahead and uh I mean you know if if the
if the show owners will not police leas
themselves then couldn't we have an
entity I mean I don't know how many
shows we have in a year what two three I
mean what's you know so I mean that
that's not a stretch in terms of
somebody taking an hour checking out all
the horses and if they do see these um
you know this cruelty that they register
a complaint and
prosecute well you know it's possible
that um the town or municipality that's
hosting any particular uh ecoin event
could send their Animal Control person
to uh to check out the animals or to
look you know look at the show and they
would be familiar enough I believe with
the criminal code to know that yeah we
are serious about um what cruelty is and
is not um and it is specifically in in
our statute um
Acts or emissions injurious or
detrimental to the health safety or
welfare of any animal and that's pretty
clear representative uh Morse thank you
madam chair I'm wondering if um perhaps
instead of listing everything
specifically as it's written currently
would you be more comfortable just
adding something about
um cosmetic changes to an animal that
could cause harm because perhaps there
are people who see some of these things
happening with horses and they don't
recognize how harmful they can be so if
it's it's something tied into language
that could be used for more animals if
it's just a you
know harmful thing that's being done for
cosmetic use instead
of uh you know like leaving a dog out in
the cold that's obvious right that it's
it's going to harm the animal but when
we're looking at things like show
animals that are going under you know
some distress because of of things that
they're doing to make them more
favorable in the show ring um I'm not
sure that I'm hearing that that is
necessarily covered in that
RSA representative comto thank you madam
chair as I sit here and listen that we
think people are going to change how
they act because we put something in law
some of this is already against the law
federally and they're still doing it so
they're already breaking the law here in
the state of New Hampshire because there
are federal laws outlawing these
things and I think by changing our
animal cruelty laws we're going to do
more harm down the than anything because
our laws are are broad enough to cover
everything that if you injure an animal
or don't permit the re required shelter
and everything else then you can be
prosecuted under the
law representative gero thank you madam
chair my apologies for coming in late we
all know this is the the season where
we've got bills off and other committees
and uh you missed the fruit cup oh of
course um one of the things that I was
unclear about when we had the hearing on
this bill was that there there were
statements made about if we you know we
have our our statute as it currently
exists then if we added to that
statute more precise language with
regard to one animal does that somehow
make it more difficult for prosecutors
to prosecute other cases of animal
cruelty right because these questions
about well well if it's not allowed in
this particular set of circumstances but
it is not specific in other parts of the
RSA right so there were questions raised
about what uh works for prosecutors and
what doesn't and my concern is that we
haven't heard from anybody who can
actually answer that question question
um I I would actually I would think it
would be beneficial for us to hear from
someone from the Attorney General's
office uh to to see if they think that
this is a useful tool for them to have
or perhaps they they think that getting
specific uh over one species of animal
for example is not helpful but anywhere
there were questions raised about what
this might mean for prosecutions and I
don't think that any of us is in a
position to really answer that question
that's a good point I would um entertain
speaking with uh the Attorney General's
office about um whether adding specific
language is would be beneficial or not I
but I
think it would seem that then you go
down the road of of specifying every
single kind of different kind of Cruelty
and you know I don't
know and I think that's a question we
could ask ask them so thank you madam ch
representative
Duty yeah it just seems to me if hor
shows are the venue that this where this
is most often seen and we have two to
three horse shows a year and Madame
chair has said that maybe this is
something that can be policed by the
local municipality and one must assume
that the local municipality is reaping
the benefit of financial benefits from
having a Horse Show there maybe people
eating lunch and that kind of thing um
then I think it should be amended so
that we have that it's mandated that if
a hor show is going to be in your
municipality that um you know a police
officer um uh it's mandated that they um
go an hour before the show or whatever
and uh inspect all of the animals I
don't think that's a a really a big
stretch why would we limit it to just
horse shows I mean there's dog shows Cat
shows there no no no but I mean it's
Horse Show I mean but we're talking
about a bill that has four cruelties
that are specific to horses and so I
think that's where we would want to
start present Murray thank you madam
chair and um just to representative
Duty's uh point I just want to be clear
here there are many different
disciplines of ecoin horse shows and
ecoin competitions so uh what is here is
generally in one certain genre of of
horse shows I just want it to be very
clear when we're talking generally about
horse shows that's not it's not
necessarily the case that those things
disciplines anyone
else representative
Penza yeah do we even know how many of
those specific hor shows
um that specific spefic discipline are
happening here in New
Hampshire i u from from uh testimony I
any so all right I'm gonna um move on to
the next
bill um HB
1680 relative to prohibiting the sale of
dogs and cats by retail Pet
Shops and I know that that's generated a
lot lot of conversation on our on our
emails
um so I mean for my own my own thoughts
on this is that you know this is this is
a bill we've heard before in this
committee
um I find it to be a um anti-business
Bill uh I think if we want to have the
conversation about where these pet
stores are sourcing their
animals from we can have that
conversation but I don't believe that
banning any particular kind of
doing representative
NAB yes thank you madam chair um I would
overall agree with that I'm a little bit
uncomfortable with Banning a specific
type of business and it feels like
that's a tough path forward in the state
um but it does seem um it's troubling to
me that there's actually not a lot of
back a lot of Regulation around the
sourcing of these animals and that seems
like that to me that seems like a really
Common Sense path forward to put some
guidelines into the sourcing of them and
um and I think there might be some
consideration there in the sourcing of
animals that come in through shelters as
well I know personally looking for a dog
that there are a lot of shelters that
offer dogs but probably do come from
puppy mills and it might be a positive
thing they're trying to rescue them from
puppy mills they're not trying to make
profit off of them but I think there's a
question of understanding where dogs are
coming from into the state I don't want
to restrict shelters because I think
it's really important that shelters in
New Hampshire are able to to support
shelters out of state that are
overcrowded and there's a demand in this
state but um so I sorry I feel like I'm
ramping a little bit but um
that's but I but I do think the
consideration of sourcing putting
guidelines around sourcing it's a it's a
really necessary path forward to ensure
the health of these animals um and I
would just comment that I was a little
surprised we didn't hear from any of the
pet stores um either by email or in
testimony and I I do sort of wish we had
so thank you sure representative Bixby
yeah um sort of following up on
representative nab's point about
sourcing I think that uh there I think
there may be uh a real issue in terms of
how animals are sourced both by pet
stores and by uh rescues and shelters
and uh that um I think we heard in
testimony from the I believe it was from
the Department that uh there
um there is
uh what the information we have about
dogs coming into the state is really
insufficient in order to be able to
track their potential for carrying
disease into the state uh there uh the
possibility of them being uh brought
from areas that uh either from from uh
breeders that are not uh following
federal guidelines or uh brought in from
other countries where there is a higher
prevalence prevalence of rabies and
others of anotic diseases uh so I think
that there's that there's a bigger issue
behind this build and whether or not we
have uh some number of pet stores in the
state that are selling animals that may
or may not have been served from puppy
mills uh and I also think that you know
uh especially given that this excludes
the existing pet stores uh there's going
to be absolutely no Market impact of the
State of New Hampshire on the uh on
poppy Mill
uh from this from the number that would
come through retail pet stores I think
that uh there another issue that uh is
sort of parallel issue is what about
internet sales where there are uh where
the uh actual transfer of the animal uh
H happens without any paperwork in a
parking lot somewhere off a
highway also not this this bill would
not do anything about about that um I
have I know people who have gotten
animals that way but uh that's that's
something else that is I think a bigger
issue in terms of problematic souring of
animals I think this bill does not
address enough of the PO possible
problems uh to make it worth
passing representative Murray thank you
madam chair I concur uh with
representative Bixby as well I think the
underlying con uh concern really is uh
around sourcing and also I agree that if
we if we're not truly clear on where
that ultimate source whether it's
instate out of state internationally
these animals are potentially coming
from there is also a larger concern for
zoonotic disease transfer if um we don't
even have a great handle on the
sourcing I know that
um was I guess Taylor Lil who had sent
us um um an email that had um State pet
store sourcing I'm trying to pull this
up
here
uh I can't get this um but she had a a
list of different states and what some
of their laws were uh having to do with
uh pets being imported into the state
and um I thought that that that was a
document that was very you know
interesting to see statute from
different states on how they control a
little bit better uh the sourcing of
these animals so um I'm going to see if
I can't pull this up and then in the
meantime representative com while you
can uh
uh no thank you madam chair um so one of
the
things
do you have copies of the state dog and
cat sourcing restrictions and breeder
standards okay yes so you thank you if
you can pass that along uh along uh you
had a uh list of Statute that Arizona
Connecticut
Louisiana uh New
Jersey Ohio and
Virginia um they have different laws uh
regarding how animals come into the
state and how animals are sourced from
different um you know licensed breeders
versus unlicensed and so forth so that's
an interesting document I think we
should take a look at representative
coma thank you madam chair what I found
interesting in the testimony is that
pent
vendors or people that transfer animals
are required to have a health
certificate uh within the last 14 within
14 days of transferring that
animal however shelters are
excluded I
think that there should be no exemption
for any animal whether it's in state or
out of state and that all animals being
transferred should have a health
certificate because that is the only way
that we're going to make sure that
people getting healthy animals and it's
the only way we can hold the
veterinarians are not going to put their
license on the line if they're not
transferring a healthy animal and a
health certificate and the reason it's
only good and I'm not sure if we change
it from 10 to 14 days but it's in that
area and the reason it's only good for
that is because they're putting their
license on the line that says at this
time this animal was healthy and they
would not even guarantee that out more
more than two weeks so if you did not
transfer that animal within the two
weeks you would have to go back to the
vet and get another health certificate
and I don't think any animal from a
shelter rescue or pet vendor or pet
store should be excluded from those
requirements and I really think that we
have an opportunity to make sure that
happens representative ger thank you
madam chair uh I want to um Echo the
sentiments of number of my colleagues
regarding the need to really get to the
root of the problem which is sourcing I
think that if frankly I think that if if
we do if we were able to solve that
problem I I think that the kinds of pet
stores we're concerned about wouldn't be
doing the business they're doing so I
completely agree with that I do want to
say that I was a little concerned during
our uh the testimony that we heard that
there were moments when I felt like
there was an attempt to kind of defend
retail pet stores by casting aspersions
on the work that sh shelters do I feel
like I've heard that echoed a number of
times and that concerns me because my
understanding is when when shelters if
you're getting a dog from a puppy mill
for example at a shelter it's because
these dogs are still rescues that that
is what they are uh right and this is an
industry that produces by Design far
more animals than the market is going to
be able to deliver to customers a to use
that term but uh so when shelters are
performing this work and some of those
dogs are coming from from these Mills
that we want to see uh
discontinued I I I just want to say we
shouldn't be putting them in the same
category as the kind of pet retailers
that we're we're talking about but
ultimately I think we do need to get to
the to the root cause representative
ktoa uh thank you madam chair and I am
not I have had dogs from shelters and
rescues
but I do believe that all animals no
matter where they come from should have
a health
certificate I think people have the
right to know that they've been examined
by a licensed veterinarian in the
state unless they're coming from out of
state where they would have a different
health
certificate but people have the right to
know that they're getting a healthy
animal and the only way we can do that
is if they have a health certificate no
matter where they come from
very quickly say I'm sorry I I agree
with with representative ktoa on that I
wasn't actually even though it came
after your comment it was not meant to
address your comments so I understand
why it seemed that way but I assure you
it was not intended that
way represent VI okay so a minor
correction uh on for I I think it might
just not have been come out very clearly
uh about how the about health
certificates uh shelters rescues Etc do
have to provide a health certificate if
the animal is coming from out of state
the the logic behind not requiring it
from instate was that and and this goes
back histo more more historically I
don't think this is as big an issue
right now was that uh be there the um
having a having to have a lot of uh of
Health certificates done for Animals uh
in shelters that were uh found that were
gotten from instate would uh put a a
burden on the nonprofits in terms of the
cost of the health certificates and that
it would uh reduce the speed with which
they could get the animals out to uh to
people who would want to have them you
take them as pets uh I'm not saying that
this is a that this is currently
good uh a good policy I'm just saying
that historically that's the way it it
was uh I think that it probably makes
sense to revisit whether or not that
exemption remains for instate animals
from uh and shelters uh I don't think
this bill is the place to do that
reexamination uh I think that uh it
probably makes sense to do a bill next
year that has to do with sourcing of
animals I don't think that this bill is
the place to do that to I don't think
amending this bill to do that is the
agree any other
comments all right thank you um we will
1572 which
is prohibiting using mRNA technology and
food and requiring the labeling of AB
insects how about who wants to start off
the conversation on
that representative saitis and then
representative
Penza um I would just say that as far as
Penza Okay so
this bill I think
um I think it makes sense I just got an
article the other day about a beef
producer that talked about um that he
would shut down his uh
manufacturing uh if he was forced to
have to inject his um animals with um
mRNA technology but I believe just like
what we what that was discussed during
the hearing when we've talked about a
lot of things that are automatically
labeled that this is really coming that
it this is new technology I get it um
but I believe the federal government is
going to have a role in this with all of
that said um you know I would I would
recommend maybe we could put this into a
interim study at this point um there's
parts of the bill that I that I I think
are just unnecessary to be in there I
think this has to do with um honesty and
labeling um I've done a little research
in in regards with the bugs and um
crickets are usually only listed as like
cricket
flower um ever rarely they're put by
their scientific name so and crickets
are I guess the only thing that is
actually used in food right now um you
know that we've heard from that are from
the Feds that are the FDA allows or
whatever so uh I I think that um I like
the idea
because I I think we should have uh
honesty in in labeling we should know
what we're eating and where our food
comes from but that's my two cents thank
you um I I just want to say that I I had
some conversations with a fellow named
Aaron Hobbs who is the executive
director of the North American Coalition
for insect
Agriculture and he sent me an email and
called me and talking about this bill
and basically let me know that that the
only insect that is allowed or
permissible in to be used as an
ingredient in
food purposefully I mean I know there's
bug parts in some of our food anyway but
uh he said the only uh insect that is
allowed by the FDA is Crickets at this
time and
um he also said that um with regard to
lab in
insects based on federal
law um all ingredients and this is in
um yeah in federal law he's he stated
the chapter and everything ingredients
required to be declared on the label or
labeling of a food including foods that
comply with standards of identity accept
those ingredients Exempted by
101100 shall be listed by Common or
usual name in descending order of
predominance by weight on either the
principal display panel or the
information panel in accordance with the
provisions of
101.2 except that ingredients and
dietary supplements that are listed in
the nutrition label in accordance with
10136 need not be repeated in the
ingredient list so you know with regard
to truth and
labeling
if there is a an insect in your food
purposefully it is supposed to be listed
by its common or usual name so that's by
federal
law um and with regard
to the rest of the the bill I
mean I I I would like to know if there's
lab grown meat in my food and I'd like
to know if there is any other kind of
bugs in my food food and I'd like to
know if there's ingredients that contain
some mRNA technology it's no different
than when we went through wanting to
have labeled GMO stuff or milk that's
got BST or and hormones or um you
know or you know any of the other
ingredients that were concerned about in
our life but by the same
token it seems to me that kind of lab
labing has to come from the federal
government because I don't know that
each individual State can dictate what
goes on labels I think that becomes a
problem because then you have these
producers that would have to have 50
different kinds of labels on their
products anyway that's kind of I just
wanted to let you know my conversation
with Mr Hobbs and take it away
representative Morris thank you um I I I
agree with what you just said I think
think that um when it comes to States
labeling food and making those decisions
it starts to get very muddy um there was
recently a study done that had uh 2% of
the hot dogs that they tested had human
DNA in them so when we start to have
these discussions about what is in our
food and you know whether or not that's
a fingernail or hair or whatever who
know but the point is if we start to go
down this road of the State of New
Hampshire telling every single food
company that they have to label every
single thing whether it's you know human
DNA in your hot dog or you know mRNA
technology or any of these things I
think that it becomes too difficult for
us to do at the state level and this is
something that needs to be taken care of
at the at a federal level representative
Bixby and then NAB and then poten yeah
so Mr mRNA has been around for hundreds
of millions of not billions of years and
uh biological organisms have uh
developed uh enzymes that break down our
Mr RNA within hours to at the most days
of the time that it enters the the
organism uh in order to get mRNA to
persist in some it would be impossible
with uh now today's technology probably
not not even within you know hundreds of
years of technology to grow figure out
how to grow an animal or a plant that
would have Mr that would have mRNA that
would function as a vaccine for whoever
was consuming it uh it's just not
possible um in terms of mRNA and
vaccines it requires an a vast amount of
engineering to get the uh the
MRNA uh from the vaccine into the cell
where it will Express itself for a
little while in order to create an
immune response and then it breaks down
uh
so uh the if a if mRNA is injected into
a uh into an animal if if if you have an
mRNA vaccine like the covid vaccine that
injected into an animal for a particular
disease that they're trying to inoculate
gas
uh the MRNA from that will be destroyed
within a day or two at the most uh and
what will be left will be the immune
immune response which will uh hopefully
protect the animal from the disease uh
so uh it's there's in terms of having
this in our food supply it's really a
non-issue uh and in terms of whether
it's something that a particular farmer
will want to use on on his or her
animals or not that is a choice that the
farmer gets to make okay and as as as
far as I know I've been ined that
there's no farm animals in New Hampshire
that have had any kind of mRNA
vaccinations available to them I don't
know that's kind of what I heard from
testimony was
that um it's not it's not available
ailable to anybody yet yeah I I believe
that there are some that there is one
swine vaccine that is uses M mRNA
technology it was it was in one of the
links of something that uh was presented
by one of our uh someone who tested oh
actually from actually from the
commissioner uh and uh but uh that's I
believe it's being used in the Carol in
North Carolina and maybe one other state
not New Hampshire not in there was no
matching of it being used in New
Hampshire get representative NAB thank
you madam chair I just wanted to um
agree with you and representative Morris
and remind people that um the
commissioner when we had the hearing
told us this would severely limit the
food options in New Hampshire and going
to really disrupt our supply chain if we
enact these requirements so for that
reason I would also agree with the
representative sopus about iing the Bill
thank you representative
Penza
I think if we're going to talk about
anything that has to do with labeling we
could take this down on a local level
since we're already requiring certain
labeling of producers here in New
Hampshire so if this was New Hampshire
specific and there's a someone that is
providing pork it's been since
2018 um there's uh some some pork
producers that are that are injecting
them with M mRNA technology but I I
think that would be the only only way
that this um this bill would have a
place to go would be if that would just
be um them having to disclose that if
some if you're purchasing meat from you
know let's say a butcher that's local
that's that I think like a local Farm
correct representative
CR thank you madam chair the uh I just
taking this bill up to 30,000 ft and
looking down on it this is like apples
oranges and peaches is you got three
completely separate things you're
talking labeling you're talking Banning
you're talking all sorts of stuff all
three of which
have um Cricket I was gonna say apples
oranges and crickets
crickets you got it so but but in my
mind none of those three are well
thought out and and if if nothing
happens no one's going to die today so I
I'm an itl for this bill um and if
there's something specific we want to
work on crickets or artificial meat or
something like that let's knock
ourselves out but right now I I just
think it's a it's like a Frankenstein
bill yeah you know but I I understand
the concern of the sponsor of the bill
in so far as you know wanting to
know what's in your food that you're
purchasing and that's a very valid
concern um but I I also don't know that
this is the correct vehicle to do that
and um I I in so far as talking about
labeling I mean I remember when we went
through the whole um compost thing of
what is it the the disposable wipes and
there wasn't really anything that we
could do as a state to say that no on
the label these are not really
compostable or flushable and that again
becomes a federal labeling
issue and um so I I don't again I don't
know that uh we can dictate what goes on
these labels for our state
representative
ktoa thank you madam
chair so my question is is as we did
with the disposable wipes we sent
something to the federal delegation
asking uh for them to look into the
labeling and would that be something
that this committee could do to look at
and say you know we really feel it's
necessary uh that people know if they're
having lab grown meet uh or something
like that I'm just just question I I
think a letter to the delegation from
this committee would be a really good
idea to say uh you know from a federal
standpoint uh we as the New Hampshire uh
house environment and agriculture
committee are interested in seeing truth
and labeling uh for the for the foods
that people are consuming and that if it
does contain insects it should say so if
it does contain lab grown meat it should
say so so um I think that's a very good
then uh let's see HP 1565
uh relative to the sale of Homestead
food to Consumers and local food
production and I wonder if the committee
would like to speak um on both bills HB
1685 since they are somewhat the
same uh just to save time and not rehash
the same thing from Bill to bill so why
don't we why don't we talk of them talk
about both bills um and just in general
the concept of of um changing the rsas
to be less restrictive for uh certain
food producers in the state and what
that would look like representative
dsy yes thank you madam chair um in
thinking about this bill uh I came to
the conclusion that both bills are in
the wrong committee and the reason I say
that is I think it was last session or
the session before we dealt dealt with
uh Homestead food act but that was
around um the um dollar amount in sales
um you know before uh lure or inspection
or or having a license would be invoked
and I think something like that is very
much business oriented it touches on
agriculture and you know I felt very
comfortable listening to that bill and
voting to approve it this on the other
hand is a bill that really requires I
think more scientific uh information and
in uh and I do not feel comfortable um
passing a bill when I really don't
understand and have a lot of knowledge U
regarding food safety issues uh I did
read uh you know a gentleman's um uh
letter that we got Mr Ren bodan from
from from nashwa who is a you know uh
taught uh
microbiology and food safety uh to the
nurses at Rivier and you know he uh was
a very good letter raised some
cautionary issues and it was at that
point that I realized I just don't have
the expertise and I don't think this
committee does I think it should be in
uh Health and Human
Services representative Bixby yeah um I
respectively I need to disagree uh
because the uh this committee one of the
one of the purviews of this committee is
the food safety um uh the Food Safety
Division of
DHHS so um uh so we very so basically if
it has to do with food safety it's this
committee's job and that's that's in
that's in our in the house rules agree
absolutely
representative
Howard thank you madam chair um I think
that if we're going to discuss the two
bills together I would I would um say
that the that kons bill um 1565 is the
better of the two um I think um I hear
from my constituents that who are in the
in this sort of business that that they
would really benefit from the expansion
I also think that the labeling that um
requirements of the US da is sufficient
for to um the fact that you're buying
the food directly from the person who
cooked it and you the ingredients must
be listed according to the USDA
requirements I think is enough to um to
protect the safety or the the validity
of the
food okay representative
kraton thank you madam chair I I agree
with representative Howard's um
assessment on the two
bills uh and I'm not taking credit for
this idea I think Madam chair it was
your idea or someone else's but uh one
of the critical parts to
um the bill is that uh it was a safety
issue and in in the business that I run
um which is a guide business we serve
several hundreds of meals a year to
wound the Warriors and other folks um we
did take the the food safe
course uh in in preparation for our
business and we modified our procedures
based on that course so I think if you
amended this bill to add a food safe
course responsibility certificate
whatever that that that would in my mind
alleviate some of that safety issue
over representative
bman thank you uh representative Kon I
hope that's the correct
pronunciation um I I I would like to add
to that I I agree with you on that as a
nurse um the one thing here you know I
totally support all of these the people
who are making the local food and
selling I mean this is a great part of
New Hampshire right this makes us who we
are um at the same time as a nurse I
haven't been fully convinced of the
safety of it and I'm not really sure how
we do that I love this suggestion um
about the food safety course um but
again I think that it it doesn't seem
like we have enough expertise here to
know exactly what would make it safe so
I um I'm not sure where that leaves us
but I would suggest that we would get
more input before we would pass
something like that representative Bixby
yeah so um I think that I I like the
concept of being able to uh produce more
Homestead Foods uh and have them and
distribute on on on a relatively limited
scale uh and I I think that um I think I
like that aspect of both bills uh I
think that as other people have pointed
out the food safety part of this is not
really here yet and I don't think that
we're going to be able to figure it out
in the next week uh and I think that uh
this is I think this is a good candidate
either for for a study committee or for
an interim study uh because I think
it'll take us more work to get all the
details worked out um we got a letter
from uh the department saying that they
would be willing to work with us on it
they are experts so we can depend on
their uh their Knowledge and Skills to
help us craft something that would uh
expand the uh possibilities for
Homestead food but also uh maintain the
food safety end of
things so here's the deal for me and
before I call on other people I mean I
have constituents that have Farms um
specifically I I'll call out a farm in
New Hampshire in um Washington New
Hampshire and um you know she she has a
a farm where she produces meat and pork
and um chicken and she does she she has
a farm store she sells muffins she sells
um cookies um all different kinds of
things she said to me you know the the
food laws are just so
um they're so weird she said that how
come I can I can bake a uh a you know
fruit pie but I can't bake a pumpkin
pie I can I I would really love to be
able to sell a chicken pot pie and keep
it either in my refrigerator case or in
my freezer or some sort of beef
casserole or something so that you know
my customers can have like a a grab andg
go
dinner and she said you know we we
Slaughter all our all our meat USDA
facilities we practice you know food
safety and I you know I don't see why we
can't um we can't sell these different
kinds of
items by the same token I also
understand from DH hs's standpoint they
don't want just random people making
macaroni salad in their bathtub and
selling it so I mean you know yeah it's
nasty that's
nasty so I mean you
know as long as you label it yeah so I I
mean I get I get the two sides here and
we've gotta I think we need to find some
kind of balance between being able to
open up the markets for our producers
who are just trying to find ways in
which to generate more income and
satisfy their
customers
versus people who don't know what
they're doing and
um I I would just like to to to find a
some some happy medium between
everything and I would be more than
willing to to do some sort of inter
study for it or see if we can't maybe
even do some kind of amendment to the
bill to move it forward representative
Penza so I come from a family that had a
restaurant uh since 1969 my father and
my brother took that over and uh he's
got five and we dabbled in that my
myself and my husband for 5 years so I'm
Serve Safe certified I kept up with that
my husband is um it's a very extensive
course and I think that that is the
amendment that could help this bill and
besides that I I'm not really sure like
there are tons of people that I know so
for example he's a caterer he works out
of his home but he has like this small
commercial kitchen and you can order
meals for a week from him and they're
all hot meals and stuff like that of
course he's serf safe certified he'll do
you know he does catering as well as
just you know meals for people that they
that can order you know busy families
and stuff like that so this is already
happening and he falls underneath a
purview but someone else doesn't
necessarily which they would be kind of
doing the same thing so I think that
this is an easy fix I'm very much in
support uh of these bills and and also
the the problems that happen with food
safety 99% of the time in the state if
you look at the numbers the numbers are
happening in restaurants this is not
something that's happening in someone's
little little kitchen so um yeah I just
been in the restaurant business I've
lived it my whole life uh NATO's Subs
that's my name name if anybody's
familiar yeah I'm Kelly NATO so yeah so
I know the space really well and I think
that um I I think we can strike a
balance and I don't want to kick the can
down the
road okay and so I know in either Bill
we would certainly have to put in any
kind of amendment to include the um
Department of Revenue so that you know
put that language in so that they're not
left out of the food and meals room and
meals tax um so that's one one amendment
that would have to be made along with
that but um the other thing is I know uh
our committee researcher did some work
for us and sent out a memo to all of us
which cited um how many food born
illnesses were reported in I guess the
past five years and I think that's makes
some interesting reading uh just so that
we're aware of what the incidents are
currently representative
moris thank you um I think that we need
to remember that our job here first of
all should be the health and well-being
of our constituents um so making sure
that we are not trying to pass anything
that could risk some health I think is
critical um I I think that looking at um
studying this a little bit more seeing
how we can amend it to move forward is a
good idea I have concerns about when
we're talking about um restaurants
having the
highest uh risk of contamination
obviously that is mostly because of the
volume that they are putting out so when
we start to have discussions about
opening up for more volume in these
small home kitchens are we going to
start to see numbers of contamination
and sickness going up in those as well
because we are expanding the volume
there so I just think that it's
something that we need to be cautious
about and well I support you know small
businesses and and um homeowners trying
to to make a little extra money when we
start talking about you know chicken pot
pie that can spoil so easily and uh
custard pies that have eggs in them if
they're not refrigerated properly and
those are the things that while it might
seem silly that you can sell one type of
pie and not another um it's really not
there there are reasons for those things
so I just think that
um we should be careful with bills like
this and loosening regulations around
health and food safety would you think
though that the folks who would be
producing these you know chicken P pie
or custard pies if they took if they
were required to take um
Safe Serve course that they would be
more cognizant of how they're handling
their food and
therefore in essence be more safe as a
result I think very likely but I think
that we also have to take into
consideration that if they are in just a
home kitchen if their um freezer or
refrigerator is not cold enough if their
dishwasher is not hot enough to sanitize
there there are so many things that if
you're just taking a course but you're
not you know in a certif kitchen and all
of those things that we should just be
considering and yet I mean we do have
Community soup kitchens and Community
potluck dinners and all that that are
also you know not necessarily following
best practices that's true but also a
lot of those places are insured you know
for safety and that sort of concern
representative
Duty um thank you for seg weighing into
to my question
representative uh that was my question
is uh liability insurance so you know I
go to the farm standand and I buy a pot
pie and I die of s
salmonella okay uh so what kind of
liability insurance are we going to
require of these um you know uh
Homestead kitchens because I don't
remember seeing any of that in the Bill
maybe it's an existing law but you know
so I I would need to know
that well I'm not sure you know we're
looking at requiring people to hold
liability insurance but certainly if
they're labeling their product saying
that um you know it's an unlicensed
kitchen or whatever the verbiage is that
the consumer is aware of whatever risk
they're
taking it's the same I don't think
that's the way the law I still think you
would be able to to Sue I mean because
nobody nobody buys a chicken pot pie
hoping to die of salmonella and I don't
think they label it like I mean you know
those things happen and all I'm saying
you know is you know like a lot of
people have mentioned here this is a
huge
responsibility and people need to
understand that this is a huge
responsibility and and so they so they
need to be educated they need to have
liability insurance because that's not
just for them it's for their customers
also if something happens and and I
think we treat this whole subject as you
know Holly Homemaker who wants to bake
some cookies and you know make an extra
$100 a week and this is serious business
and I think that there should be
something in the bill if there isn't
already in law that you know indicates
that they need to be Co covered by
liability insurance because this is very
serious
representative
Howard um I I I would be willing to work
on an amendment that would include um
the safe service um and I'd like to work
with DHHS on that um because they had a
lot to say about about inspection and
stuff like that so I I would want to
talk to them about what amendment would
work for them and I think that I think
the safe service um uh safe food service
uh certification would actually be sign
represent Bixby yeah um I I don't think
that having Ju Just um putting in the
the Serve Safe program would be
sufficient I think that it is necessary
but I think that uh the issues that uh
representative Duty brought up in terms
of liability and how that's dealt with
are important uh I believe that most
farmers markets require their vendors to
have uh liability Insurance uh and uh
there are also a number of uh there are
a number of different categories of food
that uh are hazardous in one degree or
another so I would be comfortable with
uh Ser with people being able to serve
once they had done the Serve Safe
program uh chicken pot pies or um
pumpkin pies uh or a whole range of
other sort of pre-made meals as long as
they know how to keep them safe until uh
they are they go out the door um but I
would not be comfortable with uh can
with people selling canned low acid
foods because uh if you typically with
the you know the if you eat a uh if you
get a bad meal that is um made that
typically a bad chicken pot pie will
make you uncomfortably sick for a few
days typically a case of botulism will
kill you and there there needs to be a
distinction there uh and so I'm not I
don't I think there are enough different
aspects of this that need to be looked
at carefully that we can't put something
together in the next week and pass it I
think that we need to do either a study
committee or or an interim study I think
I would probably prefer the interim
study because we could make sure it
happens and we'd control that within our
committee as opposed to hoping the
Senate will then pass it on and then
hoping that some of us get appointed to
the committee uh so but I I could not
support passing it uh with an amendment
in the next week uh I could definitely
support and would be happy to work on an
interm study representative um Mary I'm
sorry uh thank you madam chair I think
to uh representative bixby's point I'm
I'm thinking back to um mushroom
harvesting and and mushroom foraging
which I did work with the Department on
several years back um and I I I do
concur that I think inter room study
would be the best path forward to
looking at this to make sure that we
have um all of those sort of safety uh
when we're not we're not just talking
about Hass hup or Serve Safe we're also
talking about records and being able to
make sure that those are there um for
the future when we know who who has or
if they're doing a self attestation and
have completed it where that information
is being kept so I I would agree with
that this is this is something that not
just a very like quick Amendment could
be
drafted represent poens you look like
you're gonna say
[Laughter]
something let me think about that um so
I just wanted to speak to um I'm not
sure who said it over there uh maybe it
was Duty um representative Duty in
regards with um liability insurance I
strongly disagree um I think that we are
in a space where um Everybody sues for
everything so um if you know we go
around this table right now and ask how
many people have been have had food
poisoning I'm going to be able to raise
my hand four times did I ever Sue any of
those restaurants where I got food
poisoning from so I think we just have
to I think I understand uh I understand
balancing safety with also um
encouraging this private business um I
also don't think that we're going to
have people that are going to be
utilizing this making the macaroni out
of their bathtub and by the way nobody
should eat hot dogs ever again I just
wanted to say that on the record but um
so I just I I think that we have to be
careful I you know if everybody feels
that studies the way um you know I I
would love to be able to do an amendment
for this and get this pushed through but
um yeah but I don't believe that we have
to go down a path of liability insurance
and all that other stuff unless the
business Falls within those criteria
we're also looking at that goes by size
and volume and and things like that so
representative comto thank you madam
chair we have been talking about things
like this for years and we keep kicking
the can down the road far have to get
they how do I say
this sell their product donate their
Etc we are
constantly trying
to
um we have I understand the food safety
portion and the public health but yet
that we
allow I believe and I can be
corrected um but I believe that a
entity without a commercial license can
have two to four dinners or
breakfasts and serve several people at a
time with no license and no
oversight I believe that's current law
is that correct
it is thank
you we don't have
oversight and
locks and when you go to somebody to buy
a product directly from the consumer you
are assessing everything about that
person you're assessing what they look
like if their home is clean
everything and I can tell you from an
agricultural
standpoint that no farmer would ever
jeopardize your livelihood by producing
something that would harm somebody else
because word travels immediately in this
state and the same thing would go for
the homestead
cooking
and people are
struggling people are looking for means
to make ends meet and sometimes
certification but I am thinking that we
need to pass something and if it needs
to go to the Senate to be amended I
think that's where it needs to
go but people have the right to buy food
from where they want we just sat here
and talked about how we don't want to
force people to label our food because
it belongs at the federal level but then
we're telling consumers you can't buy
food from where you want
Amendment okay might drop
representative Howard you have you have
a comment I I just wanted to remind
everyone that uh representative kulan
also wanted this to be part of um the
New Hampshire offering the New Hampshire
image it's you know he wants it to be
out there wants the
agricultural food and offerings to be
more
prominent representative
Morris thank
you um
so one of the problems that I have with
that argument representative Kat is that
you're very selective on which Farmers
you support so when we have a room full
of organic farmers in here begging for
their
future
um you're not overly supportive of those
people but then you want to shove
through a bill that could potentially
endanger a lot of
people so I'm just wondering why we
continue to hear this sort of hypocrisy
of we have I would like not not like to
use that kind of language and not to
make attacks on each other okay let's
see if we can work through this issue
without using such um verbiage please
okay I I'm just curious then why we
would be so supportive of pushing
through a bill quickly quickly amended
that could potentially harm our
constituents um when we don't seem to
give that same level of thought to
promoting other
Farmers
yes thank you madam
chair I support all
Farmers certified organic
organic practicing organic permaculture
them there are other
means by sitting here and saying because
66 Farms May will have over 14 months to
find another Avenue to be certified does
not mean I don't support them because I
think that everybody in agriculture as
long as they're helping their soil and
making it
better is promoting good good management
practices for the State of New Hampshire
it is not one farmer versus another
we've gone to NOA I go to NOA
events I support
them and you can sit there and shake
your head no at me all day long but I
support agriculture 100% in the state of
New Hampshire no matter what type of
farming you're doing all right let's
bring this back to the actual bill and
and the um the things that were the the
items in the bill that are uh of
question and
uh I think I saw some other hands up
representative
Duty uh yes thank you madam chair you
know we throw away
330 billion tons of food every year that
was the last number that I heard so it's
not you know like the the
consumers of you know um the these Foods
uh can't find food someplace else and I
mean this is clearly not a program that
is set up to feed those who do not have
access to food um the beneficiaries of
this bill are clearly The
Producers okay and I think we have to um
to keep that in mind and to use the
argument to promote this bill and and I
do not feel that it is ready for for
prime time at all but to say that consu
that that consumers are being denied the
right to uh to buy what they want just
seems to me to be a little
disingenuous um because to be honest
with you I mean may maybe you see it I
do not I have not had one constituent
call me and say gee I wish I could buy
blah blah blah and I can't okay so let's
be honest here this is about the people
who are going to create a business it's
not about the consumers that's my
opinion and I and I don't think that
this is a safe
Bill representative Bixby um I would
respectably have to disagree that this
is just about the producers I think that
it is actually about a community of
people who want to have food that is
produced by people they know and I think
that uh and uh or people who may be you
know maybe one a couple of degrees of
separation but but within a but
essentially it's about wanting to have a
locally
based uh food community and uh that
involves both the producers and the
consumers and I don't think that this is
about
um that that the problem with this bill
is that is is the fundamental model I
think that the problem is that there
needs there need to be some things
ironed out to make sure that people who
are well- intended don't end up getting
into trouble and I think that
uh I think that there are some as
aspects of the bill that are fairly
obvious but I think there are others
that I think we really need to work
through more carefully with the people
from the Department who know a lot about
food safety and uh I think that this
would be a really great Bill to have
before us in a finished form next term
representative
kraton uh thank you ma'am I I uh I want
to reiterate what uh representative
Bixby just said it it is about a
community there's nothing in this bill
says anything about Farms the word Farm
is not in this bill
but it does not distinguish between
organic or regular or anything else so
he is he is right this is not about
Farms this is about a community of folks
that want to make and sell and buy food
and I'm fine with the with the uh Serve
Safe as a an amendment and I would vote
for that as an OTP but I'm also fine
with a an is you know I'm okay with that
to to strengthen it but um I I just read
the bill it doesn't say anything about
farms in here at all
over representative NAB thank you madam
chair um I just wanted to Second what
representative Bixby and Murray and also
a little bit Katon said um I I want to
air on the side of the Department of
agriculture's recommendations and I
would also like there to be a pre-cooked
meal waiting for me at home that I can
pop in the oven when I get home from
this so
um so I you know I see the value in it
and and I and I don't want to stand in
the way of that but I we have to make
this a safe process the reason we have
regulations is to keep people safe once
upon a time there were horrible problems
around food safety and this is why we
have regulations right so we have to be
careful when we dial them back um so I
am fully in support of the inter room
study and thinking about ways to make
this bill move forward and and enable
homesteaders to do this work and also to
make sure that we do it in the safest
way possible thank you representative
saitis thank you madam chair um I think
that perhaps this bill came
because um during the pandemic um we saw
bluntly how um Supply chains could be
destroyed and um we need to have food
that comes from our area we have a rich
uh history in the state and um anything
that can marry that to bring us more
healthy food food from where we
live um and I have to admit um my
godmother who was Greek you know call
her and say could you feed 750 people
tomorrow for dinner and she would say
yeah let me just take something out the
freezer because there's a lot of people
who are really good cooks and and
um you know we're not giving them enough
credit
because there's going to be bad apples
everywhere somebody's going to make a
mistake mostly it'll be an honest
mistake or whatever but hopefully we're
um strong enough to overcome this we had
a a long period when we were trying to
decide if it was legal to um buy raw
milk yeah and you would have thought
that that uh we were asking to give up
our firstborn child for Raam
mil so we get funny about
food until we don't have any and for
these people who who are trying to make
money or to to um save their
property um I mean last
year people got a huge property tax
increase so maybe that these nanas are
trying to um make up that money we won't
know but I just think that we have to
Foster and cherish every single food
source that we
have so I'd say it would you be with
them
Amendment thank you representative ger
thank you madam chair uh I I think we
should move to interim study that's
that's what I would support I want to
Echo a couple things representative
Moore said first of all we have to have
the balance I absolutely agree with with
the intent of the bill but we have to
have a balance when we uh had
commissioner Jasper here with us last
session talking about there a couple of
bills right that had to do with kind of
changing regul regarding Apple
inspections changing regulations
regarding seed inspections and one of
the things the commissioner said was
that and these were his his words and
you can hear him saying it as soon as I
so is that he resented implications that
the regulations weren't put there for a
specific reason right that legislators
had simply kind of picked a number out
of a hat uh and so that regulations are
in place because they a response to a
something that happened at some point
right so uh and and so for that reason I
think it is important for us to promote
this cause but to do so in a way that
keeps in mind that regulations do exist
for a reason and the other point that
representative Morse made that I I'd
like to second is that and I've only
been here for a year but I haven't yet
heard us make the suggestion that we
should pass a bill that we're not good
with with the idea that it's going to be
amended on the other side of the wall
that's not an argument that I have heard
anyone make with regard to any of our
other legislation so that's a reason why
I support interim
study thank
you well and
um kind of don't want to uh go against
our animal cruelty statutes and beat
longer I'm going to say that uh we our
discussion's pretty much done around
this these two bills and um let's see if
we you know I don't know if we can come
up with any kind of amendment between
now and next week if not um I'd be fine
with inm study on this too and I want to
make it very clear for this
committee when we say inter in study
that doesn't mean a dignified death it
means that we will study it and we will
come up with a
solution and present some kind of um
legislation that
is beneficial in the next for the next
term so just for the record interim
study for this committee doesn't mean
that it's just going to go away and die
somewhere with that um I guess we're
done for
today our representative Bixby yes would
it be um in order to bring up one of the
bills we were discussing last
week uh we have a little bit of time so
one not so uh I had a chance to uh talk
to our city manager about the uh bill
that uh was in response to the um
nutrients going into Great Bay and the
need to uh to um follow EP for follow
the EPA permit Rel regarding um whether
uh a sewer plant needs to be upgraded uh
Etc and uh one of the things that so I I
got a bit more of the history which I'm
not going to rehash right now um
but uh one of the things that I got from
him was that this in this is in fact a
real problem that the Department of
Environmental Services has been better
at stepping in between the EPA and the
municipalities in the last uh four three
or four years but uh that uh what might
really help is if uh rather than the
federal EPA uh issuing permits uh for uh
water quality uh if that's something
that was delegated to uh the state Dees
because that would give Dees they'd
still had to follow the same the
same uh laws but they would be able to
recognize more readily what the
communities need and be able to work out
um better accommodations uh so we might
want to amend that bill to
um uh to study making Dees a delegated
authority and also um study U
possibilities uh for uh Dees to be able
to provide more uh Municipal Aid funding
to uh communities that need assistance
uh in in meeting those guidelines so I I
I think we might want to see if we can
make that into a study committee and and
the other thing is that that bill that
really would be under the purview of
resources not under our committee so if
we can write that if we can maybe get
talk with um representative friend Zula
yes and see if uh he'd be willing to be
in support of such an amendment of a
study committee and perhaps provide some
Personnel for it then that would be very
helpful okay sounds like a plan
representative Murray uh thank you madam
chair I uh support representative
bixby's um request I do want to make
sure that we in whatever direction we
proceed that the department is obviously
brought in because I you know I just
want to make sure that they felt would
feel like they had the bandwidth to do
such a thing versus where it is now so I
could definitely support a study
committee that would wrap in um both
resources and environment and
agriculture represent U part of the
reason for doing that as a study
committee is to be able to get their
input and the other thing is that it's
also the sort of Bill that would
probably make sense to go in the first
uh term first year of the term because
it's going to have a budget impact uh
Dees would need more Personnel for that
and uh that's the sort of thing that uh
would need to U be considered in terms
of the budget yeah sounds right
okay very
good all right well um I bid we adjourn
I'm going to gavl us out and hope you
have a good rest of the evening thank
you all
fun